chers collègues monsieur le ministre
d'intérieur et des Outre-mer comme vous
le savez il est parti en au Parlement
parmi ces missions constitutionnelles de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement dès
le 16 mars dernier nous avons constaté
la recrudescence des manifestations
d'ondes non déclarées donc illégales qui
ont donné lieu à des troubles graves
alors public et pour les encadrer mais
aussi les contenir différentes unités du
ministère de l'Intérieur ont été
mobilisés dès les premières difficultés
j'ai souhaité que la commission des lois
procède à votre audition afin de
comprendre la stratégie de maintien de
l'ordre déployer par votre ministère
j'ai souhaité rappeler en préalable de
votre audition que l'État détient le
monopole de la violence légitime afin de
défendre le contrat social qui nous unit
ce recours à la force publique s'exerce
dans des limites de proportionnalité et
de nécessité en l'état nous souhaitons
vous entendre sur les événements en
violence étant déroulés à Paris et dans
plusieurs villes de province ayant
débouché sur l'interpellation
d'individus participant à des
attroupement violent non déclaré
provoquant parfois des incendies
volontaires à cette occasion et lors des
interpellations réalisées plusieurs
enregistrements vidéo ou audio mis en
lumière des violences comm par des
services de police principalement à
Paris des propos discriminatoires ou des
comportements humiliants nous semblant
excéder le cadre légal selon le préfet
de police de Paris ces actes ont conduit
à des saisines de l'inspection générale
de la police nationale parallèlement et
postérieusement et postérieurement la
demande d'audition que je vous ai
présenté sont survenues les événements
d'une extrême gravité à Sainte-Soline
dans le département des Deux-Sèvres au
motifs de la contestation de la
construction de réserves de substitution
sera sûrement identifié à aurisc
organisé par trois collectifs du 24 au
26 mars dernier était non déclaré et
donc interdit selon les termes même du
rapport de la préfète des décès une
interdiction non contestée devant le
juge administratif contrairement aux
arrêtés de la préfète des Deux-Sèvres
portant interdiction de port de
transport d'armes de munitions et objets
pouvant constituer une arme par
destination lesquelles ont été attaqués
par la Ligue de droits de l'homme la
Confédération paysanne et les udcgt et
solidaires 79
les rapports de la préfecture de police
et la direction générale de la
gendarmerie nationale font état de trois
cortèges de 2000 personnes chacun dont
deux composés d'éléments radicaux
procédant rapidement à des attaques de
contre la gendarmerie à coups de
cocktail Molotov de tirant d'une mortier
d'artifice ayant conduit avec
déclenchement de l'usage de la force
ceci indique d'une part qu'il
apparaissait clairement que l'objectif
n'était pas d'entourer le chantier de la
réserve mais d'attaquer les forces de
l'ordre en causant le plus de dommages
humains et matériels possibles c'est le
rapport de la préfète des Deux-Sèvres
d'autre part que quel que soit le site à
préserver se déchaînement de violence
organisé et coordonnées vise à mettre
en échec notre capacité à maintenir
l'ordre public et assurer la protection
des institutions c'est le rapport de la
direction générale de la gendarmerie ces
rapports d'écrire un arsenal conséquents
de 800 à 1000 individus radicaux
fortement équipés donc 400 à 500 Black
Blocs expérimentés et ultra violence aux
coordonnant par Tokyo walkie mégaphone
faisant usage d'un grand nombre de
cocktails
de mélange incendiaire un retardement de
pierre de front d'habits de bouteilles
de gaz chalumeau et disqueuse de
chantier
en réponse la gendarmerie indique avoir
utilisé 5000 grenades lacrymogène 9 89
de désencerclement 40 dispositifs des
flagrants 80 tirs de LBD donc de non
touchants par le peloton motorisé
d'intervention et d'interposition ces
deux cas faisant l'objet d'une enquête
administrative de l'inspection générale
de la gendarmerie nationale elle
considère que face à ce niveau de
violence extrême aux assauts massifs
d'individus extrêmement déterminés et
protégé des effets des gaz lacrymogènes
par leur masque il a été fait un usage
proportionné d'emplois des grenades de
désencerclement et de tir de LBD enfin
les rapports pointe pointe la carence
des organisateurs dans l'organisation
des secours laquelle a dû être palier
par l'État le bilan humain nous appart
extrêmement lourd car on dénombre 47
blessés parmi les gendarmes dont deux en
urgence absolue
et entre 17 à 200 blessés selon
différents des comptes parmi les
manifestants dont trois en urgence
absolue une polémique est apparue quant
à l'intervention des secours alors qu'il
ressort des différents rapports que ces
derniers ont réalisé leur mission dans
un contexte rendu difficile par
l'impossibilité de dépêcher des secours
sans garantir la sécurité des
intervenants SAMU et pompiers le fait
que les scores de gendarmerie était pris
à parti par les intervenants et ce qui
n'a pas empêché malgré tout l'action
d'un médecin de la gendarmerie qui a
porté ce cours à participer en gradement
blessé la localisation incertaine et
imprécise de certains blessés faute de
repères partagés avec les organisateurs
et les sollicitations nombreuses des
blessés légers ne nécessitant pas
l'intervention du Samu voilà pour
l'effet voici les conclusions que je
voudrais vous poser avant celle de mes
collègues vous avez annoncé la
dissolution de l'un des trois
organisateurs de la manifestation
illégale de Sainte-Soline quelles
raisons vous conduisent à prendre cette
mesure spécifiquement à l'égard des
soulèvements de la Terre vous avez
constaté la carence grave des
organisateurs de cette manifestation
quelles sont les actions aux
responsabilités qui seront entreprises
par l'État à leur rencontre
vous avez constaté la présence de
nombreux radicaux et Black Bloc
étrangers quel est le suivi réalisé par
nos services de renseignements
commencent leur donne-t-il avec les
services étrangers pour les identifier
les interpeller et empêcher toute
réitération et enfin nous déplorons
certains actes excédents usage
strictement nécessaire et proportionné
de la force publique pouvons-nous
connaître le nombre d'acte concernés la
durée approximative des procédures les
conséquences que vous en tirez les
suites qui seront données et notamment
l'effectivité des sanctions qui seront
prises je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés merci de me
permettre d'évoquer un certain nombre de
sujets d'actualité que nous avons déjà
évoqué soit médiatiquement soit
évidemment dans les questions
d'actualité je me permets de ce
président parce que vous m'aviez
autorisé une légère introduction
moi-même pour remettre dans le contexte
du point de vue en tout cas du ministère
de l'Intérieur les événements qui sont
passés depuis le 16 mars puisque c'est
là où on le verra le plus important et
je me suis proposé de vous faire une
petite présentation très rapide et je
répondrai à vos questions évidemment à
vous-même monsieur le Président puis
ensuite aux orateurs que que voudrait
bien désigner
donc depuis le depuis le début de
l'année mais je pourrais dire même
depuis mon arrivée au ministère de
l'Intérieur quasiment trois ans chacun
peut attester que le matcha de l'ordre
de ces dernières années de ces dernières
mois singulièrement ceux qui ont
commencé de manière massive avec
l'annonce de la réforme des retraites et
son arrivée au Parlement ce sont des
rouler sans incident majeur d'ailleurs
je le constate on aurait pu mettre tous
les Verbatim de personnes qui
considéraient que les choses allaient
changer notamment avec un nouveau préfet
de police y compris les satisfactions de
d'un certain nombre de variations
syndicale évoquant le fait que ces
manifestations qui parfois ont ramené
plus d'un million de personnes ce sont
des rouler partout sur le territoire
national pas simplement à Paris dans de
bonnes conditions j'ai fait une petite
frise rapide pour montrer que ces 8
premières journées alors qu'il y avait
énormément de monde et alors que les
services de police c'était en nombre ce
sont des roulettes sont quasiment des
difficultés si les WC existe ils sont
légers et ne connaissent pas de
blessures pas grave et sont vu le nombre
de personnes quasiment à millions en
moyenne sur les manifestations dans 300
à 400 actions en France tout à fait
relatifs et les interpellations sont
dans le Lot classique des
interpellations lorsqu'il y a plus d'un
million de personnes dans la rue on voit
bien que c'est la journée nationale
d'action du 9 postérieure effectivement
au 16 mars qui fait naître les troubles
très importants que vous évoquez puisque
là on voit qu'il y a 552 blessés
ce jour-là et il y a partout en France
et 428 interpellations je pense que
c'est très important de le comprendre
parce que les manifestations en tant que
tel le maintien de l'ordre en tant que
tel ne pose pas de problème ce qui pose
de problème ce que je vais essayer
d'expliquer c'est les les guérillas
urbaines je les ai qualifiés comme tels
les violences
urbaines et évidemment dans la journée
nationale du neuf il n'y a pas sainte
solide ce sont que des des choses qui
sont en marche de la manifestation
officielle et d'ailleurs si on avait
fait un découpage on aurait vu que la
manifestation classique du neuf n'a posé
quasiment aucun problème pour le
syndicats à l'exception d'entrer dans le
caresse syndical de poursuite de
personnes qui seraient effectivement
qualifiés comme des Black Blocs on s'en
est d'ailleurs expliqué avec la
responsable la technique a d'ailleurs
été changée pour le 10 et d'ailleurs ça
a été cela a été vu je veux donc
souligner que ce n'est pas en tant que
tel les manifestations qui posent des
problèmes que cette journée particulière
du neuf qui a fait naître énormément de
blesser chez les forces de l'ordre comme
chez les manifestants beaucoup plus
quand même chez les forces de l'ordre et
des interprétations en très grand nombre
pourquoi parce que l'explication que je
fournis avec les services du sein à
l'intérieur c'est que cette
manifestation à partir du 16 mars
notamment cette deuxième journée
d'action a fait naître une présence
extrêmement forte de ce que les services
de renseignement appellent l'ultra
gauche qui ont souhaité infiltrer le
mouvement social et en prendre la
direction si j'étais provocator je
dirais prendre en otage dans le contexte
de cette journée d'action je vous ai mis
quelques citations des notes de
renseignement qui étaient à ma
connaissance
qui était à ma connaissance je rappelle
d'ailleurs monsieur le Président
commission que au parlementaire que il y
a une délégation renseignement et que
c'est pas le moteur renseignement
évidemment accès à toutes les notes
classifiées du ministère de l'Intérieur
je ne saurais trop vous recommandé si
j'ose dire d'utiliser ce droit vous
apprendrez dans la pluralité beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses évidemment que que
décrivent les services de renseignement
que je ne peux dévoiler ici
dans ce dans ce contexte donc 10 par
exemple les notes du service
enseignement soit de la DRPP soit des
enseignements territoriaux la joie
d'action est pris en main par des
cortèges d'ultra gauche la journée
d'action dans une trentaine de villes on
pense notamment à ceux de l'Ouest de la
France mais aussi de la région
parisienne bien évidemment fait que les
buts de ces personnes de reprendre
directement représentant l'institution
républicaine donc au policier aux
gendarmes aussi aux élus à l'intégrité
physique des représentants des forces de
l'ordre et puis on voit aussi les cibles
qui sont soit les forces de l'ordre des
dégradations de sites institutionnel ce
qui explique qui est très nombreuses ATT
entre les commissariats les préfectures
les sous-préfectures les mairies je
pense à Bordeaux évidemment je pense à
Lyon je pense aussi au 11e
arrondissement à Paris et bien
évidemment ce qu'ils appellent les
symboles du capital
donc cette journée d'action ces deux
journées d'action qui se sont succédées
depuis 16 mars on voit qu'il y a une
poussée extrêmement forte du fait de
l'ultra gauche des violences qui n'ont
rien à voir en tant que tel avec ces
manifestations
1851 interpellation monsieur le
Président
299 atteintes contre des institutions
publiques qui n'ont parfois absolument
rien à voir avec la réforme des
retraites tout le monde sait que le
maire de Bordeaux est un maire Europe
Écologie Les Verts qui dépasse favorable
à la réforme des retraites la Mairie du
11e arrondissement n'est pas tenu par
des élus de la majorité
des commissariats des sous-préfectures
des préfectures qu'on a attaqué à coup
de côté Molotov mais aussi des conseils
départementaux c'est pas extrêmement
nouveau rappelez-vous pour avoir une
connerie l'ultra gauche on était pris
par l'hôpital Necker chacun s'en
souvient l'idée l'idée assez forte que
nous constatons c'est que les atteintes
aux actions publiques étaient ciblées et
organisées et parfois totalement en
marge au sens du parcours de la
manifestation 132 atteinte de permanence
de parlementaire
alors j'ai juste
je me permets de il y a des vidéos que
peut-être
vous n'avez pas pu voir dans les médias
évidemment un truc à votre disposition
là nous sommes avec des habitants de
l'ordre à Lyon dans une rue
perpendiculaire à la manifestation on
voit évidemment que ce soit des pavé ils
sont je trouve de façon extrêmement
impressionnante la scène a duré plus de
12 minutes pour les représentants des
forces de l'ordre à Dijon puisque ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que la
question était prise en pack
la préfecture de police c'était on n'est
pas dans la manifestation on est
évidemment dans une route à porticulaire
à la manifestation
je pense pas que ce soit de l'ordre de
la manifestation classique
à Paris je voudrais souligner le drame
qui a été évité par les policiers et les
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris extrêmement
courageux
extrêmement courageux d'un immeuble
en flamme où il y avait
une dizaine de personnes non des enfants
qui ont été évacués quand on nous
demande pourquoi on intervient pas
pourquoi on intervient des jeux des
bâtiments publics là on est place de
l'autre côté de la place de
l'opérames qui ont pris par Adventure
n'empêche pas les incendies par
propagation qui puisse arriver et
vraiment on doit sapeur-pompiers de
Paris et aux policiers aux gendarmes
d'avoir empêché un drame de ces
personnes qui ont été évacuées
évidemment en marge de ces
manifestations vous l'avez ok vous même
monsieur le Président à Sainte Soline
qui s'est déroulée le week-end qui a
suivi la journée nationale d'action la
9e la contestation est essentielle
puisque depuis 2021
plusieurs dégradations
si vous voulez on va écouter le ministre
plusieurs dégradations ont été déjà
repérés avec déjà des interpellations
des préjudices à plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros pour les agriculteurs
en 2022 il y a eu je rappelle une
manifestation très importante notamment
la deuxième qui a fait naître 61 blessés
chez les gendarmes dans plusieurs traits
grièvement et on avait évoqué à peu près
effectivement 500 personnes du train à
gauche ou black bloc dans les
affrontements très violents vis-à-vis de
la police et la gendarmerie
et donc nourri de ces expériences
malheureusement 2022 et par les notes de
renseignements qui nous évoquaient une
internationalisation une
europeanalisation de la violence nous
avions préparé évidemment ce rendez-vous
de sainte Soline qui était annoncé
notamment par soit des mouvements
pacifistes qui se sont réunis à Mel ou
il n'y a d'ailleurs pas eu d'incidents
soit évidemment confrontations en direct
avec les bassines
concernées une manifestation donc non
déclarée qui a fait l'objet d'un arrêté
d'interdiction par la préfète le 17 mars
avec deux conférences de presse de
Madame la préfète des Deux-Sèvres avant
la sainte Soline plus une du procureur
de la République encore la veille je
crois que c'était le jeudi qui précédait
ce week-end là je vous l'avais dit
vous-même monsieur le Président
l'arrêté d'interdiction de manifestation
n'a pas été contestée par les personnes
organisatrices mais évidemment des
guillemets la préfète des Deux-Sèvres
après préalablement fait part par
courrier dès le 10 mars aux
organisateurs identifiés et je pense que
c'est très important et notamment dans
le cas des enquêtes judiciaires qui sont
ouvertes pour mettre en cause la
responsabilité des organisateurs qui
sont d'ailleurs responsables des secours
je le rappelle pour toute manifestation
chacun le sait quand il en organisent
c'est le cas notamment bien sûr
décidément de la terre mais aussi de
bassines non merci de Confédération
paysanne de son attention d'interdire la
manifestation le courrier est resté sans
réponse suivi la communauté de presse
annonçant que la manifestation était
maintenue montrant donc bien qu'ils
avaient reçu ce courrier puisque ils
évoquaient le fait que la manifestation
était et maintenu le 12 mars qu'on suite
au courrier du 10 entre le 17 et le 22
mars 8 arrêter la traduction ont été
pris par la préfète avec des choses
je crois assez raisonnable comme éviter
de transport d'armes ou la circulation
dans un agricole on pense au tracteur
puisque l'une des difficultés c'était
l'arrivée des tracteurs sur le site même
de la manifestation soit par ceux de des
agriculteurs de la Confédération
paysanne soit par ceux qui appartenaient
à des associations à des groupements de
faits et qui n'avaient rien à voir avec
un outil agricole qui ont été pris par
la préfète je voudrais moi aussi
souligner que notamment l'arrêté de
transport d'armes a été contestée dans
le tribunal administratif notamment par
la Ligue des droits de l'homme et qu'à
chaque fois le tribunal administratif a
donné raison à la préfète des
Deux-Sèvres
donc c'est toujours dans la conformité
du droit que la préfète des Deux-Sèvres
agi j'ai rappelé les conférences de
presse dès la préfète pour bien annoncer
renouveler le fait que l'interdiction
des manifestations avait été prise et
nous avons eu beaucoup de réunions
techniques sous l'autorité de mon
cabinet du directeur général de la
gendarmerie nationale de moi-même avec
les préfectures concernées et notamment
une réunion présidée par la première
ministre le 22 mars avec les ministres
de la Justice des agriculture et de
d'écologie
Christophe Béchu
nous avons pour répondre aussi une
partie de vos questions monsieur le
Président fait des contrôles en amont
puisque les services de renseignement
des pays étrangers nous évoquaient que
de nombreuses personnes ultra gauche ou
d'écologie radicale souhaitaient se
rendre sur Sainte Soline je pense
notamment à des Espagnols des Italiens
des Suisses et des Allemands dans ce
cadre et conformément au droit nous
avons mis en place un dispositif très en
amont du 24
000 véhicules contrôlés aux frontières
et à proximité de sainte-solines va
procédure ouverte suite à ces contrôles
rien que dans ces contrôles en amont 62
couteaux ont été saisis 67 boules de
pétanque 13h 5 matraques en bas de
baseball 6 bidons d'essence 20 et au sol
et bobonne de gaz cette mortier
d'artifice le rendez-vous était donc
assez peu festif 3200 gendarmes les
policiers ont été déployés notamment
autour
des bassines mais pas simplement à noter
enfin que je leur ai dit à Monsieur
présent la commission des lois les
gendarmes n'ont pas pu faire voler les
en revanche nous constatons que je mets
des manifestants entre guillemets les
casseurs en l'occurrence on fait usage
de ces drones
c'est donc une sorte de renversement de
l'usage de l'outil médiatique et de
surveillance des casseurs surveiller les
gendarmes mais les gendarmes par la loi
ne pouvaient pas surveiller les casseurs
en avril 2019 le Conseil constitutionnel
censuré la mesure rappelez-le à situer
une interdiction administrative de
manifester d'une durée maximale d'un
mois pour les individus qui étaient
autour d'acte de violence qui nous
aurait permis sans doute d'éviter un
certain nombre d'individus très
dangereux à Sainte Soline qui
participait eux-mêmes aux manifestations
sauvages guerrier
urbaine pour les manifestations contre
les retraites on pense notamment à
Rennes à Nantes ou à Lorient c'était une
mesure portée par mon prédécesseur
Christophe Castaner je rappelle qu'elle
était censurée par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc aussi pour répondre
à peut-être par anticipation à une
question les gendarmes ne pouvaient ce
jour-là pas faire voler de drone et ne
pouvait pas interdire les individus
manifestation ils ont respecté le droit
et malheureusement
ce ce cette action des individus
violents et des drones ont permis une
attaque extrêmement violente des
personnes qui sont pris au gendarmes
il est totalement documenté là encore
monsieur le Président j'encourage la
délégation parmentaire enseignement de
se faire communiquer les notes que
l'ultra gauche était extrêmement
présente à Sainte Soline dans la dans
les manifestations
je mets encore là aussi des guillemets
de contestation directe envers les
gendarmes c'était moi le cas évidemment
dans les manifestations de mail il est
sans aucun doute que à peu près
deux centaines de personnes
radicalisées à l'ultra gauche ou à
l'écologie radicale suivie par les
services de renseignement notamment la
DGSI était présent sur site
sur les 8000 manifestants les services
mais ça va d'ailleurs pensent
qu'aujourd'hui un millier de présents
dans l'ultra gauche française et
d'Europe était venu effectivement
chercher cet affrontement je rappelle
que ensuite à la suite des contrôles
plus de 800 objets qu'on peut qualifiés
d'armes cocktail Molotov ou arme blanche
ont été saisis chacun se rappelle qu'il
y a 48 gendarmes laisser dans certains
grièvement et quatre individus bicycle
grièvement dans de très grièvement parmi
les manifestants
peut-être pour venir sur la chronologie
parce qu'elle a fait parler beaucoup et
j'en remercie d'ailleurs le travail qui
a été fait journalistique de maître fin
à des fake news dont on parlera
notamment sur l'intervention des secours
dès le vendredi nous avions alors que
les manifestations interdites étaient
quand même organisées pour le lendemain
nous avons eu des envahissements de voix
mettant ainsi en danger les manifestants
et les personnes qui étaient membres des
trains donc la circulation a été arrêtée
entre Angoulême et Poitiers sur LGV
Paris Bordeaux on va ISMANS et puis 300
Black Blocs ont dès le vendredi attaqué
les voies
et un certain nombre de barrières de
gendarmerie le 25 au matin
arrivé de la majorité des convois qui
s'était qualifiée en trois types de
convois il y avait qu'on voit
ultra je reprends les mots avec des
couleurs différentes
un convoi
famille et puis qu'on voit contestataire
classique non violent vers 10h les
cortège s'élancent vers la bassine qui
était distante de 6 km à 12h40 il y a
déjà des premières échauffourées avec
les gendarmes puisqu'il reçoit alors des
tirs de mortiers des cocktails Molotov
et les gendarmes répliquent avec les
lacrymogènes
le 25 après-midi les choses évidemment
sont ce que les Français ont vu devant
ébahi leur poste de télévision vers 13h
trois cortèges se sont menés vers la
bassine qu'on appelle la bassine 15 pas
très loin de sainte-solide en effet à
13h05 le groupe d'environ 1000 Black
Blocs se détache et fonce vers les
gendarmes qui sont en défense avec des
fortement très dur que on a tous eu à la
télévision
ils sont extrêmement armés quatre
véhicules sont alors incendiés avec vous
l'avez vu des cocktails Molotov d'un
genre nouveau qui ne mettait pas
qui n'était pas forcément très très
connue aussi des services de police dans
leur ensemble et j'utilise alors les
grenades anti
désencerclement pardon les grenades
assourdissantes et lacrymogène pour se
dégager ils sont alors à quelques mètres
des casseurs
je rappelle d'ailleurs que jamais les
gendarmes
ne lâcheront leurs lignes et il n'y a
pas eu d'offensive de bons offensifs des
gendarmes dans les dans les champs de
sainte Soline vers 14h20 les Black Blocs
se replient et puis de nouveau
vers 15h il y a un nouvel assaut rendant
évidemment extrêmement confus les choses
on reviendra sur la question du médecin
et du salut mais je veux noter déjà que
dès 14h35 la gendarmerie nationale par
un peloton spécialisé en cadre un
médecin du GIGN c'est un médecin
militaire en détachement auprès de la
gendarmerie nationale et un infirmier du
GIGN pour fendre la foudre le style et
essayer de se couvrir les les opposants
qui sont à leur grièvement blessés
notamment un qui sera pris en charge
plus tard par le SAMU ils y parviennent
malgré le harcèlement auquel ils font
preuve d'ailleurs le groupe de gendarmes
qui accompagne le médecin est obligé de
se replier et le médecin du GIGN seul
extrêmement courageuse malgré les jeux
de pierre et mal les insultes et le
harcèlement va apporter les premières
soins premier soin aux victimes à 17h30
donc les choses se sont déroulées en
deux fois deux heures les assaillants
font un retour alors qu'en base en
commettant d'ailleurs des dégradations
on pense notamment à des canalisations
qui sont pris à partir pendant que
l'État s'occupait d'évacuation des
blessés
je souhaiterais revenir monsieur le
président
sur cette affaire qui touche
profondément l'honneur de l'État et des
gendarmes comme quoi les gendarmes
auraient empêché les secours
d'intervenir bon je pense que tout le
monde a désormais compris que ce n'était
absolument pas le cas plutôt ce que nous
en savons à 13h49 un premier appel aux
pompiers a été fait à 13h50 au SAMU et
il y aura une géolocalisation qui est
pas forcément évidente dans un champ
distant de 6 km il y a pas de rue avec
des numéros de rue je veux le dire pour
ceux qui n'ont pas vu les images à 14h01
c'est-à-dire vraiment 10 minutes une
fois entre l'appel et la géolocalisation
le SAMU est enclenché et parallèlement
les pompiers qui étaient déjà proximités
cherchent le blessé au milieu des champs
sans succès et connaissant d'ailleurs
pour une partie d'entre eux là aussi des
harcèlements de la part des manifestants
je mets évidemment des guillemets à
14h45 le SAMU s'engage à son tour à
l'intérieur du site pour se rendre sur
la nouvelle géolocalisation réussie à
être évoqué et indicatif il est ralenti
à plusieurs reprises sur par des
manifestants eux-mêmes soit parce qu'ils
sont blessés et qui veulent des soins
soit parce que ils prennent à partie ce
SAMU entre 13h45 et 14h50 la gendarmerie
envoie de nouveau son médecin et auprès
du blessé sont arrivés le SAMU il est en
3 minutes sur place et fait le premier
bilan médical et engage des premiers
secours il est lui-même je l'ai dit
l'objet de projectile il reste au côté
du blessé l'hélico de la gendarmerie
est mobilisé pour évacuer se blesser en
l'occurrence les médecins lui-même ne le
souhaite pas le faire monter dans cet
hélicoptère puisqu'il n'est pas
médicalisé il faut donc attendre
l'hélicoptère du SMUR qui qui arrive
je voudrais quand même vous alerter sur
cette planche que je mets évidemment à
votre disposition distribué à Sainte
Soline vous constaterez qu'elle est fait
avec un certain graphisme et une
certaine recherche si nous
la regardons de près elle est sur les
réseaux sociaux il y a pas vraiment de
difficulté c'est ce qui a été distribué
aux manifestants de sainte-solins
c'est-à-dire en gros ne pas donner son
identité ne pas avoir de plaisanter sur
soi se présenter directement dans les
hôpitaux sans jamais passer devant les
services de secours qui seraient sur
site toujours payé en argent liquide
voilà on voit bien que il y avait une
organisation il y a des numéros de
téléphone qui sont d'ailleurs
intéressant pour les services de
renseignement
cette c'est assez étonnant il prévoit
évidemment les violences il y a avant
l'événement pendant l'action après
l'événement il y a évidemment les
équipements que l'on doit faire pour
être au rendez-vous de confrontation
avec les gendarmes je crois que comme on
dit comment on dit dans le langage des
policiers des gendarmes il y a
préméditation je je pense qu'on peut
dire qu'après méditation
alors pourquoi Monsieur le Président
cette distinction sur la manifestation
du du la 9e manifestation et celle de
Sainte-Soline parce que le problème en
France n'est pas tant les manifestations
il y en a une trentaine tous les jours
toutes les week-end pardon après autour
de la préfecture de police à Paris il y
en a une centaine chaque semaine pour
diverses raisons il y a des très grosses
manifestations qui sont organisées
depuis très longtemps il y a énormément
de gens au 31 décembre on l'a vu encore
par exemple aux Champs-Élysées 2
millions de personnes à Paris le sujet
n'est pas tant les manifestations que
l'infiltration par l'ultra gauche de ces
manifestations et ce n'est pas un sujet
français c'est évidemment un sujet
international c'est un sujet européen
comme je vais essayer de l'évoquer là
encore les zones de renseignement sont à
votre disposition chacun se rappelle du
G20 de Hambourg en 2017 discernement de
violences pendant trois jours regardent
de nombreux personnes ultra gauche
françaises étaient présentes j'évite de
Rostock en 2007 ou d'ailleurs t'ont
donné lieu appelons-le à un millier de
blesser le G20 de Londres en 2009 qui a
conduit évidemment à la mort d'un
passant mais aussi des zones à défendre
les zones de non-droits les ades en 2023
il y a pas assez longtemps que ça
c'était il y a trois mois à luzerat je
ne suis pas germaniste mais je pense que
ça se prononce ainsi de violent
affrontement au cours desquelles des
policiers des tirs d'engins
pyrotechnique et j'ai productibles on
fait naître 70 blessés et 20 à côté
manifestants en janvier également
Atlanta il y a eu une ZAD pour empêcher
les constructions de l'école de police
par rapport ultra gauche à mort et de
nombreux blessés bref on peut multiplier
ces moments où la violence politique
vient prendre la violence sociale
qui est en otage par des manifestations
tout à fait bien sûr légitimes et
surtout les sujets que veulent évoquer
les citoyens
alors là ça c'était en janvier 2023 en
Allemagne pour ceux qui pensent parce
que j'entends beaucoup de choses sur le
fait que seule la France est concerné
donc il y a deux mois
[Musique]
donc c'est maintien de l'ordre rural si
je veux dire allemand devant l'ultra
gauche allemandes je rappelle ce qui se
passait en Italie particulièrement
impressionnant les images
[Applaudissements]
les questions les commentaires c'est
après
et donc notre notre difficulté
évidemment et c'est le cas de tous les
de tous les patriotes je n'en ai pas de
doute c'est évidemment une très gauche
qui est extrêmement présente depuis
quelques années on va dire depuis le
début des années 2000 qui revient sur le
vent de la Seine première grande
mobilisation notamment pendant le la
question du printemps 2006 à la
méditation du CPE mais chacun se
souvient de Sivens sous un gouvernement
qui je crois était socialiste avec le
décès d'un jeune homme et 58 policiers
gendarmes blessés
Notre-Dame-des-Landes où je rappelle que
108 gendarmes ont été blessés évidemment
une contre-société avec des armes
extrêmement importantes je rappelle la
loi travail ou la violence était alors
inégalée là aussi gouvernement
socialiste en 2016 et qui n'a évidemment
d'ailleurs rien à voir avec les
violences que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui elles étaient beaucoup plus
fortes encore à l'époque lors de la loi
dite el khomri et puis évidemment chacun
se rappelle que pendant les gilets
jaunes pendant les premières semaines
des choses se passent le plus
correctement possible et puis ensuite
les services de renseignement aux
documentés et désormais ce n'est pas
contesté l'ultra gauche a infiltrer une
partie des revendications pour les
radicaliser et ça a été notamment le cas
à Paris
monsieur le Président je pense que vous
allez auditionner beaucoup de mises à
l'intérieur qui se succéderont ici quel
que soit les gouvernements puisque les
services de renseignement évoquent 42
projets contestés de même que sainte
Soline sur le territoire national
on voit bien d'ailleurs que c'est une
qu'importe le projet pourvu qu'on est la
contestation et la violence contre la
force les forces de l'ordre ou l'état il
y a des choses très différentes qui
peuvent être apparents apparues comme
polluantes bien sûr ça peut être le cas
d'extension de l'aéroport de Lille ou ça
peut être le cas de l'autoroute
Castres Toulouse mais il y a aussi des
choses qui semblent être écologiques je
pense au FGV par exemple la construction
de ligne de TGV en tout cas c'est
contestations sont extrêmement
nombreuses importantes sur tout acteurs
national avec une présence plus forte
dans l'Ouest et dans le sud-ouest de la
France nous savons d'ores et déjà que
nous aurons des volontés d'avoir
d'installer des ADDES ce qui était le
cas à Sainte Soline nous aurons
développés de manifestations extrêmement
violente contre les forces de l'ordre
des contre les symboles de l'État c'est
le cas je l'ai dit pour l'autoroute 15 -
Toulouse qui sera sans doute le prochain
le prochain objectif de de ces ultra
gauche mais sur les 42 projets 17 sont
qualifiés par les services de
renseignement comme étant susceptible
d'entraîner une radicalisation des
actions comme sainte Soline évidemment
c'est une préoccupation pour les femmes
et hommes politiques bien sûr mais pour
tous les citoyens
alors je terminerai par les réponses de
l'État d'abord je rappelle que devant
votre propre commission monsieur le
Président j'ai évoqué le fait que le
l'état devait moderniser son schéma de
maintien de l'Orb mais aussi donner
davantage de moyens pour être au
rendez-vous de ces radicalisation parce
qu'une fois qu'on a fait ce constat il
faut évidemment adapter nos moyens nous
avons rédigé un nouveau schéma de
maintien de Lens c'est la première fois
en France que ce schéma est rédigé et
écrit il a d'ailleurs été validé par le
Conseil d'État
la difficulté et évidemment la formation
du maintien de l'ordre des policiers des
gendarmes qui sont spécialisés puisque
c'est un métier spécifique il manque des
policiers des gendarmes chacun sait que
15 escadron de gendarmerie et Cérès ont
été supprimés les 20 dernières années et
que nous sommes seulement en train de
les recréer ça prend du temps de créer
si j'ose dire des postes de policiers de
gendarmes qui sont spécialisés dans le
dans le matcha Noord je rappelle que
vous avez voté dans la Love Me onze
unités de force mobile qui est donc bien
évidemment les policiers et les
gendarmes spécialisés je veux évidemment
dire que les centres d'entraînement
évidemment aujourd'hui sont limités
puisque seuls Saint-Astier existe ou la
gendarmerie vous le savez Excel
notamment sur un maintien de l'autre on
pourrait qualifier de plus rural même
s'il évidemment de l'aide à le maintien
de l'ordre urbain et donc nous avons
acheté un site au ministère défense à
Villeneuve-Saint-Georges qui est en
train d'être aménagé pour évidemment à
son entraînement en région parisienne
pour que à la fois les agents de la
préfecture de police spéciale match
alors les policiers des gendarmes
puissent entraîner en commun
ce n'était pas le cas avant mon arrivée
au ministère de l'intérieur mais ils en
mettent tous les membres du corps
préfectoral et c'est bien logique sont
formés au maintien de l'ordre et nous
avons mis fin à un certain nombre
d'utilisation
d'armes notamment de grenades contenant
de l'explosif puisque seuls les grenades
assourdissantes à la main ou lance
grenade sont utilisés évidemment pas des
grenades lacrymogènes qui sont bien sûr
autorisés
la difficulté du match alors c'est
notamment ce qu'on avait vécu pendant
l'article 24 c'est la liaison entre ceux
qui font l'information et les services
de police et les manifestants ou les
casseurs je crois que il y avait aussi
une question de clarification des
sommations on en reparlera tout à
l'heure j'imagine dans les questions
les dotations de caméra piéton
généralisée qui quasiment maintenant
équipe quasi intégralité de la police et
de gendarmerie à quelques exceptions
près mais cela est en train de terminer
d'être livré ce qui évidemment change
beaucoup les choses le rapport de la rue
avec Monsieur Delarue qui nous a
beaucoup aidé sur le travail avec
l'identification des journalistes on
pourrait en reparler mais qu'évidemment
à la fois essentiel et complexe et les
encadrements les mesures dans
l'encadrement suite à la décision du
Conseil d'État du Juin 2021 j'entends
parfois dire que la NAS a été interdite
c'est évidemment faux mais la NAS a été
imaginée différemment par une décision
du Conseil d'État ce que nous appliquons
bien évidemment
des moyens inédits pour le maintien de
l'ordre je rappelle que nous créons ne
serait-ce que cette année énormément de
postes pour les engins mobiles SRS
puisque nous omotons à quatre sections
notamment les unités de CRS ils étaient
à trois sections lorsque je suis arrivé
au ministère de l'Intérieur nous devons
d'ailleurs 40 jours de congés parfois
aux policiers aux gendarmes puisque les
CRS et gendarmes mobiles font beaucoup
de missions ils tiennent les stations
balnéaires l'été les stations de sport
d'hiver d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup
d'élus quelques sortes politiques qui me
les réclament pour leur présence bien
évidemment les manifestations sportives
extrêmement nombreuses culturelles
d'ailleurs on a vu l'amour que parfois
on avait pour les policiers et des
gendarmes et notamment les CRS lors de
la discussion autour des JO 2024 ou tous
les festivals culturels évoquaient
l'importance qui est le CRS présents
autour de leur festival et donc
évidemment c'est unités de force mobile
sont très très sollicitées et parcourent
beaucoup de la France je voudrais aussi
souligner monsieur le président de la
commission des lois qu'en outre-mer ils
ont été particulièrement sollicités
c'est le cas à Mayotte c'est le casier
sur Nouvelle-Calédonie quand ils sont
des référendum c'est le cas évidemment
aux Antilles en Guyane ou votre
commission Madère était saisie sur la
violence qui s'y déployée seul les
unités de force 1000 sont capables de
rétablir la paix publique comme ils le
font d'ailleurs puisque en général après
leur envoi on entend plus parler dans
l'actualité de leurs actions
et évidemment sur la question
déontologique ce qui me permet de
répondre à l'une de vos questions
également au point où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui il y a 41 enquêtes
judiciaires qui sont ouvertes à l'IGPN 4
alli GGN et qui sont sous l'autorité des
magistrats par ailleurs sans que
magistrats s'en soit saisi j'ai demandé
trois enquêtes à administratives
traitées par l'IGPN et une par l'iggn et
les
comment dirais-je des sanctions puisque
je reviendrai soit dépendent de
l'autorité judiciaire et on attend la
fin évidemment de l'action judiciaire
lorsqu'il y a des mesures de mise en
examen qui prévoit notamment que les
policiers gendarmes doivent sur la voie
publique doivent être désormais doivent
plus aller dans telle ou tel service
évidemment de les pronoms immédiatement
et nous attendons la fin de l'enquête
judiciaire quand le prévoit la
jurisprudence pour prendre les sanctions
administratives et lorsqu'il n'y a pas
de sanctions judiciaires lorsqu'il y a
pas d'enquête judiciaire l'IGPN et
l'hygiène désormais en trois mois rendre
leur rapport je rappelle d'ailleurs que
à ma demande et depuis la loopnie nous
publions les rapports de l'IGPN et de
l'iggn et que les directeurs généraux
prennent leur après le conseil de
discipline dans les trois mois qui
suivent les enquêtes administratives
donc pour les trois plus une personne
qui sont concernées par ces enquêtes
administratives non couverts par
l'action judiciaire il y a des trois
inspections en trois mois pour rendre
leur rapport ils seront publiés et des
sanctions seront connues bien sûr
immédiatement je rappelle que les
policiers légendes représentent moins de
5% de la fonction publique et qu'il
concentre 55% des sanctions
disciplinaires
je pense que on pourrait faire une
comparaison avec les autres ministères
il est normal que les policiers
gendarmes soient contrôlés c'est tout à
fait logique ils ont la force mais
d'autres ministères ont aussi beaucoup
de pouvoirs et je suis pas certain que
100% des fonctionnaires de tous ces
ministères ne fassent jamais aucune
erreur ou jamais aucune difficulté il
est donc faux de dire que les policiers
gendarmes ne sont pas contrôlés et
sanctionnés
pour terminer Monsieur présent sur vos
questions le soulèvement de la terre
contrairement à ce que j'entends n'est
pas une association il a donc pas d'atte
à la liberté d'associations c'est un
groupement de fait c'est à dire quelque
chose qui est caractérisé par les
services de renseignement par la
direction de la serge juridique
ministère de l'intérieur des groupes de
téléphone commun des appels
téléphoniques nombreux des réunions dans
les mêmes endroits des tracts ou des
communiqués de presse signés donc il est
évident que ces personnes sont
rassemblées en vue d'obtenir évidemment
un certain nombre d'objectifs les
soulèvements de la terre pour une très
grande partie d'entre eux sont partis
des gens qui étaient déjà servis par les
services de renseignement depuis
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et le
contradictoire que nous avons envoyé
cette semaine évidemment auquel nous
regarderons attentivement les réponses
pour le ministère de l'Intérieur évoque
des appels au soulèvement comme son nom
l'indique et les appels à la violence et
notamment la violence contre les
institutions républicaines ou contre les
sur les actions en responsabilité
monsieur le monsieur le Président il est
évident que l'État regarde avec
attention la responsabilité des
organisateurs notamment à Sainte solide
où il est tout à fait documenté
désormais et sera fourni à la justice le
fait que malgré les interdictions
répétées de la préfète et de l'État et
connu de tous connu de tous il
s'agissait pas d'un arrêté
d'interdiction publiée dans une
sous-préfecture quelconque il y a eu une
organisation répétée et notamment une
organisation violente répétée pour une
partie de cette manifestation et je veux
le rappeler ici que la question qu'on
aura à trancher la justice c'est qui
était responsable notamment des secours
je rappelle que le droit Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires c'est que
l'organisateur est responsable de sa
manifestation et c'est aussi le cas dit
la jurisprudence lorsque la
manifestation est organisée sans support
juridique c'est à dire lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de déclaration
enfin vous évoquez les black-bocs les
black-bocs étrangers il est difficile de
définir leur nombre bien sûr ce qui est
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y a une
européenneisation au moins de cette
violence
nous avons procédé de nombreux
interpellations aux frontières de
l'Italie de l'Allemagne et de la Suisse
sur les renseignements donnés par les
services étrangers là encore monsieur le
Président je vous encouragerai à
consulter la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement parce que il n'est pas
classique de donner des informations
qu'on donnait les services étrangers
mais ces interpellations et ses actions
avec les services étrangers d'ailleurs
nous leur rendons bien l'appareil
lorsque nous savons qu'il y a ce genre
de choses préparer notamment en
Allemagne récemment ont permis d'éviter
qu'à certaines personnes extrêmement
dangereuses soient présentes sur place
après vous connaissez le droit mieux que
je ne peux le connaître en tant que
président de la commission des lois on
ne peut pas interpeller et faire
condamner de façon préventive des
personnes dont on sait qu'il commettrai
contact répréhensible et violents même
donné par un service étranger on ne peut
les empêcher de rentrer sur le
territoire national c'est ce qu'on
appelle une iate une interdiction
d'arriver sur le territoire national et
saisie a été ont été prises par la DG
par la DGSI en lien avec la DPI ont
permis en effet qu'un certain nombre de
personnes très violentes étrangères ne
se rendent à Sainte Soline
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc j'ai
36 intervenants je rappelle que la durée
est de 2 minutes pour chaque intervenant
et que je serai intransigeant compte
tenu nombre d'intervenants et que je ne
prendrais pas davantage d'inscrits que
j'ai sur ma liste aujourd'hui donc je
donne la parole à Monsieur Éric
Fouillard le groupe Renaissance
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre plus de 800 policiers gendarmes
ont été blessés entre le 16 et le 27
mars dernier au nom du groupe
Renaissance je tenais à leur adresser
notre plein et entier soutien j'en
profite pour rappeler que les cortèges
syndicaux nous ont montré que lorsqu'il
n'y a pas de violence il n'y a pas de
blessé policier gendarme ou manifestants
nous observons depuis plusieurs années
l'augmentation de l'intensité de la
violence est constatoires à quel point
elle est organisée armée et financé
c'est pourquoi avec mon collègue
jérémyordanoff nous travaillons sur
l'évolution de l'activisme violent pour
mieux comprendre ces phénomènes face à
cette violence nos forces de sécurité
intérieure incarnent ce bouclier
républicain qui protège nos institutions
démocratiques et nos concitoyens du
désordre ils tiennent bon pour protéger
notre République notre État de droit
face à une violence que rien ne peut
justifier
dans ce contexte nos forces de l'ordre
doivent continuer à s'adapter à user de
la force légitime et proportionnée dans
le respect du cadre légal c'est pourquoi
lors des gilets jaunes nous avons fait
évoluer notre doctrine d'emploi en
créant les bras même pour répondre aux
besoins de mobilité et de projection de
nos forces dans Paris ou l'utilisation
de Squad de Squad à Sainte-Souline
vous avez eu raison de rappeler la
réalité des attaques que subissent nos
forces de l'ordre les bons incendiaires
les couteaux et les h saisi à Sainte
Soline en sont quelques exemples
monsieur le ministre face à l'évolution
de l'activisme violon et à ce
déchaînement de haine en quoi les braves
aiment incarnent une nouvelle doctrine
de maintien de l'ordre y a-t-il selon
vous de nouvelles évolutions possibles
et comment rompre l'escalade de la
violence peut être voulu par certains
et plus largement ne peut-on pas penser
que ça dure en organisée avec des
individus comme vous l'avez rappelé
venant des quatre coins du monde serait
motivés par une idéologie visant à
déstabiliser notre pays
merci Monsieur Michael taverne pour le
groupe rassemblement national
[Musique]
ensuite à Sainte-Souline nous avons tous
vu la violence exercée je l'ai connu
personnellement c'est un moment très
difficile et j'ai été surpris de vous
entendre dire concernant les gendarmes
avec les quads et les lanceurs de balle
de défense qui a le 40 qui serait
suspendu parce qu'ils n'ont pas respecté
les ordres donc sans enquête
administrative et sans décision de
justice c'est quand même incroyable
d'entendre dire un ministre ils seront
suspendus sans même avoir les
aboutissants ensuite concernant la
proposition de loi sur la récidive
c'est une proposition de loi déposée par
notre collègues Naima muchou qui a été
rejeté par votre majorité et les
policiers ont été désagrément surpris de
voir la majorité refuser justement
l'alourdissement de peine pour les
récidivistes qui agressent les élus les
policiers les gendarmes donc mes deux
questions
concernant les le maintien de l'ordre
sur place est-ce que il faut privilégier
beaucoup plus les forces mobiles au
détriment des unités locales parce que
c'est une spécificité et pourquoi vous
avez refusé un amendement sur la
formation j'ai déposé la locmi alors que
vous savez que la formation c'est une
priorité merci Madame Clémence guetter
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre d'abord à Sainte Soline le
chaos s'est abattu sans distinction
surtout les manifestants pour
l'essentiel qui était venu
tranquillement et en famille ensuite la
loi et les libertés ont été bafouées on
a ainsi pu observer un tir tendu de
grenades lacrymogènes des tirs de LBD
effectués depuis des quads les secours
empêchaient d'arriver ou largement
retardé un journaliste placé en garde à
vue sans motif des observateurs privés
de protection et de leur matériel mais
surtout c'est un désastre humain qui a
été organisé c'est 250 blessés parmi les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
des dizaines de mutilés et le coma dans
lequel un manifestant est toujours
plongé ce désastre c'est votre échec
monsieur Darmanin dans cette période
danse en mobilisation chaque jour la
presse dévoile vos mensonges et du bout
des lèvres vous reconnaissez des écarts
isolés quand ce sont les consignes
ziniques qu'il faudrait arrêter en
matière de maintien de l'ordre il ne
s'agit pas ici de responsabilité
individuelle mais d'un naufrage
institutionnel en Suède et en Espagne on
déploie des officiers médiateurs au
Pays-Bas des unités de la paix mais en
macronie au lieu de désescalades on
expérimente la répression quoi qu'il en
coûte pour 4000 manifestants donc selon
vos chiffres 3200 policiers gendarmes
déployés 500015 grenades tirées au lieu
d'apprendre de nos voisins le maintien
de l'ordre à la française fait
honteusement la une de leurs journaux le
rapporteur spécial de l'ONU s'inquiète
d'une réponse de l'État largement
disproportionnée vous savez que vous ne
pourrez pas empêcher les conséquences du
changement climatique en me disant sur
le seul usage de la force en faisant de
la vieille politique au service du vieux
monde comme le dit Philippe Descola avec
vos injonctions automates à condamner
les violences qui n'ont jamais été et ne
seront jamais les formes d'action que
nous prenons vous ne réussirez pas à
justifier votre de recours systématique
à une réponse strictement autoritaire et
répressive vous osez les insultes et
faites des diversions périlleuses mais
vous ne pouvez pas indéfiniment blâmer
vos opposants pour vos propres errements
monsieur le ministre cette stratégie
mène le pays dans une impasse quant à
les boutirait les leçons de sainte
Soline monsieur Éric Ciotti pour le
groupe républicains
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre de nous avoir
apporté
ces éléments
chiffrés imagés qui ont montré le
déchaînement de violence de la part de
l'extrême gauche à l'encontre de nos
forces de police un déchaînement de
violence qui s'inscrit très clairement
dans une stratégie de déstabilisation
stabilisation de destruction des
institutions de la République c'est bien
cela qui est en cause et d'ailleurs je
pense qu'il faudra qu'on se saisisse un
jour des dangers que ces groupuscules
qui sont soutenus par des groupes
parlementaires ici même par des
parlementaires qui étaient présents à
une manifestation interdite génère pour
la République le vrai débat il est là
c'est les menaces que l'extrême gauche
que l'ultra gauche représente un carne
aujourd'hui et c'est ma première
réaction
à ces images et à ce bilan extrêmement
lourd qui ont eu à supporter nos forces
de l'ordre victimes des armes par
destination que vous avez cité boule de
pétanque mortier chalumeau barre de fer
caillassage les
les individus je dirais même les
barbares qui étaient là n'avaient qu'un
objectif c'était tué des gendarmes ou
des policiers et créer le chaos le
deuxième élément c'est je voudrais
apporter un soutien total à nos forces
de l'ordre qui sont depuis des années
Miss sous pression attaquée qui sont de
plus critiqués qui sont menacés dans
leur famille dans leur logement qui sont
pris pour cible je crois que le devoir
de la représentation nationale et
d'apporter un soutien sans réserve aux
policiers aux gendarmes et de dire que
notre système de maintien de l'or est un
système équilibré et qui a toujours
veillé à préserver les vies monsieur
alors on va s'écouter jusqu'au bout
Monsieur Emmanuel Mandon du groupe
démocrate
oui merci
monsieur le Président
comme de nombreux Français j'ai été
monsieur le ministre a été frappé par la
violence des images et des graves
incidents sainte Soline au point d'y
trouver un motif supplémentaire
d'exprimer mon soutien au gendarme qui
sont employés à protéger le site
exécutant les instructions qui leur ont
été données en particulier
d'éviter à tout prix le contact et tout
corps à corps
les intentions destructrices d'un grand
nombre de manifestants ne faisaient pas
mystère
pour ce que nous avons vu ce qui a
contraint les forces de l'ordre à
opposer une réponse toujours
proportionnée aux agressions de plus en
plus violentes dont ils ont été victimes
nous savons qu'elles se sont ainsi
trouvées confrontés à des groupes
muscules venus dans le dessin délibéré
de brisé par tout moyen et sans égard
aux conséquences la ligne de défense
tenue par les gendarmes dès lors il
devenait inévitable que des blessures
graves surviennent chez les assaillants
comme chez les gendarmes nous le
déplorons pour autant l'emploi de
Hachette de pied de biche de produits
incendiaires tout ce qui a été cité de
disqueuse de chalumeau les caillassages
systématiques non manifestement aucun
rapport avec l'usage légitime du droit
de manifester
donc ici les auteurs de ces violences
ont confisqué leur profil la liberté
d'expression du plus grand nombre
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre d'abord monsieur le ministre
en premier bulle dire que nous
condamnons toutes les violences d'où
qu'elles viennent y compris parfois de
la part de manifestants mais
vous ne pouvez pas la description vous
avez faite les descriptions que vous
avez faites sont sûrement et sont réels
mais vous le pouvez pas résumé des
semaines de manifestation à ce que vous
avez montré et surtout vous ne pouvez
pas passer sous silence les raisons pour
lesquelles nous en sommes arrivés là il
y a eu de toute évidence une évolution
de la doctrine d'emploi de la police
nationale à partir du 49.3 et quand je
dis doctrine d'emploi je dis donc
instruction nous avions auparavant des
manifestations qui étaient encadrées
dans un esprit de d'apaisement et nous
sommes passés systématiquement après à
des affrontements systématique je le
disais et surtout et surtout un distinct
vous avez montré un certain nombre de
vidéos qui sont à contrôles monsieur le
ministre nous pourrions en montrer
également d'autres
qui sont bien sûr qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui attestent de
comportements que je pourrais qualifier
deux des viandes de la police nationale
on a vu des gazages de leaders syndicaux
qui étaient identifiés on a vu des nats
assez systématiques on a vu l'usage des
LBD y compris attirent tendu on a vu des
matraquages aveugles et on a même vu on
a même vu des gendarmes mobiles faire la
leçon à des policiers de la brave qui se
croyaient autorisé sans aucune raison de
pratiquer quasiment des charges de
manifestants alors que ce n'était
absolument pas nécessaire et on a
parfois le sentiment monsieur le
ministre que vous ne maîtrisez plus
votre police et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous pensons que il y a la
nécessité absolue d'une reprise en main
de la police la question est de savoir
comment vous allez le faire monsieur le
ministre faute de quoi notre sécurité
qui doit rester républicaine pourrait
basculer dans une république sécuritaire
Monsieur Didier Le Maire pour le groupe
horizon
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président cher et cher collègue
l'actualité récente a mis en évidence
les difficultés que peuvent rencontrer
les secours pour accéder à un terrain
d'opération vous l'avez dit très
justement monsieur le ministre et je
vous remercie d'avoir montré ces images
parce que j'entends ici et là des
commentaires des commentateurs sachant
difficilement pour certains ou certaines
d'entre nous ce que peut être la réalité
de nos forces de l'ordre ce à quoi ils
sont confrontés régulièrement maintenant
malheureusement
envie de vous dire que c'est assez femme
et ses hommes à laquelle auxquels je
pense aux policiers aux gendarmes qui
sont là pour faire en tous les cas
régner l'ordre public et défendre la
République se rempart qui nous paraît
encore si important dans notre
démocratie bien évidemment nous sommes
moi-même et le groupe horizon du côté
des forces de l'ordre et nous leur
apportons tous leurs soutien parce que
rien absolument rien explique une
violence telle que des boules de
pétanque rempli de clous de cocktail
Molotov que sais-je ou que de hache que
de couteau retrouver sur des
manifestants en face dôme et de femmes
qui sont là uniquement pour faire leur
métier alors lors de cette manifestation
il paraît que le délai d'intervention et
les conditions d'accès des secours et
ont été très critiqués permettez-moi de
par mon expérience de celle de
sapeurs-pompiers ceux à qui je pense que
ça soit les sapeurs-pompiers que ça soit
les équipes du Samu qui chaque matin
lorsqu'ils font leur prise de garde
connaissent les risques auxquels ils
peuvent avoir à faire face mais en tous
les cas j'en connais aucun qui est là
pour en tous les cas prendre soit une
boule de pétanque soit un pavé soit quoi
que ce soit qui pourrait les mettre en
danger c'est aussi ça qu'il faut prendre
en compte alors en tous les cas encore
une fois il y a quelques années on nous
parlait de violences urbaines c'était
déjà un scandale à l'époque j'ai été
formé à cela avec d'autres gens de ma
Corporation aujourd'hui on parle de
guérilla alors Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît nous
expliquer comment combiner les objectifs
d'intervention de sécuriser cours avec
celui de la nécessité de porter secours
dans le cas des manifestations illégales
madame Elsa faussillon pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine
monsieur le ministre la gestion du
maintien de l'ordre dans notre pays ces
dernières semaines n'a pas choqué que à
l'intérieur de nos frontières en juger
la presse internationale vous avez vu
aussi que le Conseil de l'Europe et le
rapporteur de l'ONU se sont inquiétés
d'un usage excessif de la force ce qu'on
voit depuis le 49-3 c'est un usage
massif d'armes mutilante d'un usage de à
multiples reprises de techniques qui
sont incompatibles entre elles NAS plus
gaz lacrymogène mais aussi des
arrestations et des détentions abusives
qui ont un seul but dissuadé les
manifestants d'exercer leurs droits or
vous le savez monsieur le ministre à
présent participé à une manifestation
non déclarée n'est pas illégal il n'y a
pas un pays en Europe dans lequel lors
de la dernière décennie il y a eu autant
de morts ou de personnes dans le coma
lors d'opération de maintien de l'ordre
je parle également des éborgnements ou
de personnes mutilées les gaz et
grenades touchent les personnes sans
distinction nous pouvons en témoigner
des vidéos que nous pourrions vous
montrer également les coups de matraque
sont donnés sur tous types de
manifestants et la France est le seul
pays d'Europe avec autant de dégâts
collatéraux il y a donc un problème
systémique que vous tentez de nier soit
au travers de mensonges soit au travers
d'un vocabulaire Fourtou c'est comme si
vous mélangiez la nups et les Brigades
Rouges vous confondez la crise sociale
et la guerre et vous utilisez le
vocabulaire d'extrême droite à l'image
de ce terrorisme intellectuel qui relève
d'une stratégie dangereuse de
dépolitisation des affrontements les
gardiens de la paix que vous aimez
appeler fils et fille du peuple ne
devrait pas avoir pour mission de mater
le peuple et alors quand il y a des
dérives vous assurez qu'il y aura des
enquêtes que vous ne dites jamais c'est
combien les sanctions sont faibles à
l'image de la faire du Burger King en
2021 quand il y a eu sanction la moitié
état de simples avertissements monsieur
le ministre est-ce que vous cherchez à
apaiser le pays ou simplement aller
chercher toujours plus en plus de voix à
droite pour vous assurer le destin que
vous imaginez
un petit rude et dentelles à Strasbourg
lorsqu’elle reçoit des tirs de LBD
depuis des quads en mouvement là encore
pas tout à fait dans le cadre ou
lorsqu'ils se font rouler dessus à moto
par la brave m là on est carrément hors
cadre alors vous avez beaucoup insisté
sur l'ultra gauche des diapos entiers
alors moi je vais juste vous rappeler un
truc c'est que l'ultra gauche les Black
Blocs ils ont une haine viscérale contre
les écologistes pourquoi parce qu'on est
en mouvement pacifiste alors je sais
qu'à l'intérieur des NAS on est
vachement collé serré mais en fait être
collé serré ça fait pas de la proximité
idéologique en tout cas donc ce serait
bien d'arrêter de raconter des fake news
c'était le titre d'une de vos diapos
mais je pense que vous avez déjà vécu ça
dans la manif pour tous d'ailleurs vous
savez quand on a peur de ne pas survivre
au milieu des gaz et du reste bref mes
questions monsieur le ministre c'est à
quel moment on a basculé dans le chaos
qui est dénoncé même par les États-Unis
et vu que vous avez pris exemple de
littérature je vous rappelle qu'elle
luttera on n'a pas fait la Une
internationale dessus donc compte tenu
de l'Arsenal quel dispositif de ce cours
avait été prévu monsieur le ministre
Hassan Soline et quelle sera
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai été élu dans la septième
circonscription de Paris qui comprend la
place de la République la place de la
Bastille la rue Saint-Antoine le
faubourg Saint-Antoine ou encore les
boulevard Beaumarchais Richard Lenoir et
Voltaire sinon sont des quartiers de
Paris où les manifestations le plus
souvent lieu ce sont des espaces de
rassemblement symbolique qui
s'inscrivent dans l'histoire des
mobilisations sociales de notre pays je
sais que les organisations qui déclarent
une manifestation ont à cœur de défiler
sur ses parcours et leur droit de
manifester est absolu dès lors que
l'ordre public est respecté or depuis
plusieurs années ces quartiers ou des
gens vivent et de nombreux commerces
sont situés ont eu à connaître de
mobilisations importantes parfois
violentes impactant la qualité de vie
des habitants et l'attractivité des
commerces en plus des manifestations
habituelles des poubelles ont été
incendies ces derniers temps faisant
prendre des risques à la population et
des tactiques visant à l'épuisement de
nos forces de l'ordre sont à l'oeuvre
générant des troubles récurrents il faut
accepter que la Ville de Paris et s'est
mobilisations soient fidèle à son
histoire néanmoins le respect des
commerçants des habitants et de leur
tranquillité ne doit pas être oubliées
je sais que vous y travaillez avec le
préfet de police et la manifestation de
demain se déroulera d'ailleurs dans un
autre quartier de Paris mais pensez-vous
que des parcours alternatifs puissent
être plus régulièrement organisés ou
suggérer aux manifestants afin que les
que les activités de ces quartiers est
un peu de répit dans un contexte de
baisse d'influence de visiteurs après la
diffusion massive des images de feu
déclenchées dans la capitale ces
dernières semaines je vous remercie
monsieur Jordan
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à réaffirmer mon soutien et
celui du groupe RN aux forces de l'ordre
qui travaille sans relâche pour que les
manifestations se déroulent dans les
meilleures conditions possibles chaque
jour le maintien de l'ordre et le
résultat d'un équilibre entre liberté
constitutionnelle de manifester et
respect de l'ordre public derrière cet
équilibre subtil il y a des hommes et
des femmes ceux qui viennent manifester
légalement ce qui assure l'ordre public
et parfois des casseurs d'extrême gauche
au-delà de la question de la doctrine
liée au maintien de l'ordre il faut agir
pour que les manifestations se déroulent
dans la légalité et que l'ordre public
soit assuré le mieux possible face aux
nouveaux types de manifestations de ces
dernières années qui sont de moins en
moins structurés et parfois illégales
donc non déclaré il convient d'augmenter
les effectifs et les formations des
forces de l'ordre sous le quinquennat
Nicolas Sarkozy 15 escadron de
gendarmerie mobile ont été supprimés et
les effectifs ont étudiés au sein des
CRS soit un total ou une perte de 2000
emplois à temps plein
dans votre loi de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur que nous avons
voté il est prévu la création en 2023
2024 de seulement quatre compagnies
républicaines de sécurité CRS et cet
escadron mobile de gendarmerie alors
Monsieur le Ministre pourquoi ne pas
avoir augmenté ses effectifs plutôt des
2017 vu l'ampleur des manifestations et
la réalité sécurité du pays pourquoi ne
pas avoir recréé un minimum les
effectifs que nous avions en 2007
d'autant que les manifestations depuis
largement évoluées avec de plus en plus
de casseurs de plus en plus de
manifestations illégales non déclarées
et quelles sont les évolutions que vous
allez nous proposer dans la formation du
maintien de l'ordre
pour les forces de l'ordre comme
l'arabelais tout à l'heure mon collègue
Michael Tavern nous avions proposé des
évolutions dans le cadre de la locmi que
vous n'avez pas appris en compte mais
ils ne sont nous que il faut augmenter
la formation et les moyens des effectifs
de police de gendarmerie qui a sur
chaque jour lors de la France car il est
temps de rendre aux Français un pays
calme et apaisé
Martin
merci merci beaucoup nous nous notre
préoccupation première et de faire le
lien entre les consignes que vous avez
donné et le chaos qu'on a pu constater
nous interrogeons la question de
l'interdiction de la manifestation qui
est à la fois empêche un dialogue
constructif avec les organisateurs mais
qui a été vécu assez paradoxalement
puisque lors d'un certain nombre de
kilomètres chacun a pu circuler en mode
en mode en mode manif donc nous
interrogeons d'abord cette interdiction
nous interrogeons et son efficacité et
son absence par la même de possible
encadrement le recours à des armes
supplétales nous nous sommes le seul
pays en Europe à utiliser ce type ce
type d'armes évidemment elles sont
dangereuses évidemment elles augmentent
la tension entre la police et les
manifestants alors que c'est bien à
l'inverse qu'il faudrait faire
qui a donné des consignes qui ont
autorisé les policiers qui ne peuvent
pas échapper au cadre au cadre qu'un
ministre de l'Intérieur leur donne
comment se fait-il qu'ils aient pu tirer
dans tous les sens comment se fait-il
que l'on ait pu voir des policiers dit
brave m juger sur leur mobylette pendant
que l'un d'autres tirent une grenade
entière tendue directement vers vers les
manifestants vous l'avez compris ce qui
nous intéresse c'est de comprendre et de
connaître le lien entre les consignes
que vous avez donné et la situation qui
a été constatée comme l'augmentation de
la mise en danger des blessés lorsque
ceux-ci était protégé par un certain
nombre de personnes dont des députés
d'ailleurs avec leur écharpe donc a
priori tout à fait reconnaissable
comment se fait-il que ceci ait été
l'objet d'un certain nombre de grenades
qui leur sont tombés dessus alors qu'ils
étaient bien évidemment pacifiques et en
position protection qu'avez-vous demandé
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre université commissariat
vandalisée entrée de mairie incendie et
usage en nombre de cocktails de mortier
d'artifice de mélange incendiaire à
retardement projection de billes d'acier
et j'en passe les mécontentement les
colères et les manifestations ne peuvent
être synonyme d'émeutes et d'anarchie
rien ne justifie la spirale de la
violence entre manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre et de secours la
destruction de bien public ou privés
jusqu'au permanence d'élus ne peut être
légitimée dans un état de droit les
républicains seront toujours du côté des
défenseurs de l'ordre des policiers des
gendarmes des pompiers des forces de
secours car ils sont la force à la loi
nous combattrons sans relance sans
relâche ce qui à l'extrême gauche attise
la haine fracture sciemment le corps
social et souple sur les braises du
mécontentement encourageant de fait les
casseurs les plus radicaux
ils espèrent uniquement récolter les
fruits politiques du chaos quelle
attitude anti républicaine et
irresponsable monsieur le ministre gérer
le maintien de l'ordre c'est le
maintenir et devait vous devez être un
des garants de l'unité du pays aussi
dans ces circonstances troublées nous
saluons votre fermeté votre volonté de
mettre fin à ces séquences dramatiques
pour notre pays et je veux saluer ici le
grand professionnel Alice de nos forces
de l'ordre aussi nous souhaiterions
connaître d'une part le bilan humain
précis chez les policiers nationaux les
gendarmes je voudrais associer aussi les
policiers municipaux et les pompiers le
nombre de blessés dans leur rang à
l'issue de ces journées de contestations
d'autre part la raison pour laquelle le
bilan judiciaire avec 5% des garde à vue
qui sont suivies de poursuite et si
faible et enfin alors que nous avons
assisté à de véritables scènes de
guérilla je pense particulièrement à
Sainte Soline je souhaiterais que vous
nous fassiez part de vos intentions afin
de faire respecter à l'avenir les
interdictions de manifester je vous
remercie
monsieur Ludovic Mendes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre depuis le début des
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites nous avons pu voir que dans la
grande majorité ces 6 sont bien
déroulées malgré l'appel permanent de
l'extrême gauche à la ferrure depuis
l'utilisation du 49-3 par madame la
Première ministre cette même extrême
gauche qui se veut de moins en moins
républicaine appeler à bloquer le pays
par la force s'il le fallait d'ailleurs
un député qui était ici présent à
légitimer l'utilisation de la force et
de la violence pour faire tomber la
réforme en cours voire même le
gouvernement cela s'est même démontré
par le beau spectacle de départ la
collaboratrice de ce même député
spectacle de non-respects des lois de la
République spectacle par l'insulte et la
provocation de force de l'ordre tout
cela mis en scène par des vidéos où l'on
constate que cette collaboratrice
conteste les ordres et les sommations de
l'agent de police que l'on peut voir
pour terminer cette mise en scène et
suite au refus de collaborer l'agent a
fait usage de gaz lacrymogène justifié
par le comportement de cette personne
cette vidéo virale n'est qu'un exemple
parmi tant d'autres nous pourrions
parler d'utilisation illégale de drone
de montage photo de vidéo etc je tiens
aussi à rappeler ici que l'utilisation
des mots gazés rafle répression sont une
insulte à notre histoire et aux victimes
de la barbarie partout dans le monde
dont dans certains pays qu'ils osent
lever au rang d'exemple avec cette
stratégie de désinformation de
travestissement de la réalité par
l'extrême gauche et souvent utilisé par
l'extrême droite pour essayer de
justifier le fait que d'après eux vous
les êtes impuissant à rétablir l'ordre
dans notre pays que nous contestons bien
entendu monsieur ménis comment vous
pourrons-nous contre-attaquer comment
comment pouvons-nous utiliser la loi
pour vous protéger les forces de l'ordre
sur le sujet Comment pouvons-nous
définir une stratégies de communication
pour permettre à nos forces de l'ordre
de répondre aux attaques qu'il subissent
sur les réseaux sociaux par des montages
vidéos et photos par des personnes
elles-mêmes parfois représentantes de la
République
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre nos forces de l'ordre subissent
toujours plus la violence de l'extrême
gauche et des Black Blocs lors des
manifestations ou des actions dont des
élus d'extrême gauche se rendent
complices que ce soit en se rendant dans
des manifestations interdites ou en
soutenant ouvertement le saccage et les
violences je veux apporter ici tout mon
soutien et j'ai un souci mon groupe du
Rassemblement national aux membres des
forces de l'ordre attaqué et blessées
ces dernières semaines monsieur le
ministre depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant des manifestations légitimes
et autorisées contre la réforme des
retraites ont lieu si nous pouvons noter
qu'au début ces manifestations se
déroulaient dans le calme il n'aura pas
fallu attendre longtemps pour que
l'extrême gauche Vienne gangrener les
cortèges alors Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur la
capacité et la méthode employée pour
permettre aux agents exerçant les
missions de maintien de l'ordre d'isoler
ces criminels du reste des manifestants
et de procéder à leurs interpellations
je vous remercie
le président monsieur le ministre ne
t'inquiète pas la prochaine fois qu'on
vient tu monteras pas dans le car pour
aller au commissariat tu vas monter dans
un autre truc qu'on appelle une
ambulance pour aller à l'hôpital tu as
fait comment le voyage du Tchad c'est un
titre de séjour tu vas être placé en
garde à vue et demain tu as une aucune
TFC fini coup menace racisme rouler sur
un manifestant ce n'est pas que de
l'inquiétude que nous éprouvons face au
comportement de ces agents de la brave m
à l'encontre des manifestants mais de la
honte et de la colère honte de voir de
tels comportements colère de voir que
vous justifiez cela par la fatigue le 22
mars face à la multiplication des
violences policières de ces agents nous
vous adressons une demande de
démantèlement de la brave m aucune
réponse de votre part vous couvrez
toujours
voiture pour dissoudre cette unité de
police ou les policiers se comportent
comme des miliciens monsieur le ministre
allez vous respecter le droit de
manifester et notamment démanteler la
brave m ou bien allez vous continuer de
Nasser l'expression populaire et
d'assumer d'être le ministre de la
matraque monsieur le ministre et Jeanine
faudra-t-il un nouveau malicou séquine
pour enfin vous faire revenir la
résidence Monsieur Didier Paris pour la
fin de cette première salle alors on va
on va conserver notre calme chacun est
libre de ses propos même outranciers
devant la commission des lois Monsieur
Didier Paris
merci monsieur le Président je vais je
ne vais pas avoir de propos outranciers
je crois qu'une grande majorité de nos
concitoyens ne comprennent pas
finalement la situation dans laquelle on
se trouve et qui voit tous les jours des
violences complètement à justifiées par
contre ils comprennent très bien que
elles n'ont qu'une seule vocation à
déstabilisation de notre République
comprennent très bien aussi qu'elle est
très largement instrumentalisé par un
groupe politique celui de la Nuxe
c'est une perte de sens en général une
vraie perte de sens étonnante
comment est-il possible qu'un préfet
soit obligé de prendre un arrêté
d'interdiction de porter des armes dans
une manifestation comment est-il même
possible pire encore que des gens
puissent contester devant un tribunal
administratif un arrêté de telle sorte
alors vous avez donné une grande un
grand nombre de précisions sur la
manière de répondre à cette situation
sidérante monsieur le ministre nous vous
en remercions et nous sommes évidemment
à votre entier soutien j'ai juste deux
questions pour compléter cette Arsenal
si je puis dire vous avez évoqué
la dissolution probable de soulèvement
de la terre soulèvement avec un S ce qui
pose problème c'est une organisation de
fait vous l'avez dit est-ce que il est
possible de est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire si vous prévoyez d'autres
dissolutions de cette nature dans quelle
champ son jeu de mots comment les choses
vont se dérouler et deuxième question
vous avez évoqué la constitution d'une
structure en tisane est-ce que vous
pouvez devant un représentation
nationale nous donner des précisions sur
la manière dont vous l'envisagez quelle
est là encore son champ d'action les
méthodes que vous pensez pouvoir
utiliser et le résultat qu'on peut tous
ensemble en attendre la
fixation de points de cette nature
paraît tout à fait scandaleuse et au
cœur même de du mode de comportement de
ces manifestants merci à vous merci
monsieur le ministre pour la vos
réponses à cette première salle de
question
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
alors peut-être je vais essayer de faire
dans l'ordre non pas d'importance mais
des intervenants pour essayer d'en
oublier personne et de faire des
réponses courtes mais j'espère
argumenter je comprends la volonté de
contrôle du législateur c'est bien
normal et c'est bien démocratique envers
le gouvernement sur cette question
importante d'utilisation de la force
Monsieur pouya Merci de vos
interventions vous allez évoquer la
question de la braven qui a été évoqué
de d'autres manières par d'autres
intervenants d'abord je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens si je peux me permettre
qui évoque
la bravm sans savoir exactement ce que
c'est d'abord quand on veut dissoudre la
bravance ça peut être étonnant parce que
ça n'existe pas c'est pas une unité le
problème c'est quoi la bravème c'est
quoi la bravème c'est des personnes qui
sont des compagnies d'intervention donc
évidemment former au maintien de l'ordre
évidemment fondateur j'ai vu fleurir le
fait qu'il n'était pas formé au maintien
de l'ordre ils sont évidemment formés à
votre chatboard les compagnies
d'intervention de la préfecture de
police qui utilise des motos n'ont pas
pour intervenir c'est pour ça que les
parallèles avec des affaires dramatiques
il y a 30 ou 40 ans son nom outrancier
mais insultant et surtout est totalement
ignorant bon et ce déplace pour ensuite
intervenir puisque les manifestations
aujourd'hui lorsqu'elles dégénère et
même lorsqu'il y a d'autres
manifestations sauvages qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les manifestations classiques
utilisent désormais beaucoup plus de
mobilité des manifestations chacun le
voit dans leur violence ont changé et
donc les compagnies attention pour être
parfois se déplacent à pied parfois se
déplace en voiture ou en camion de
police votre gendarmerie et parfois
maintenant se déplace en moto et on
n'intervient pas en moto on descend de
la moto et ensuite la personne qui est
derrière puisque son dos sur cette moto
et la personne d'accompagne
l'intervention qui est une personne
différente de la personne qui conduit ce
n'est pas le même service qui conduit la
moto que ceux qui sont derrière et qui
vont ensuite dans les rues de Paris je
reprends l'intervention pour les élus
qui sont élus à Paris vous avez Paris
nous a pas ça vous a marqué et à la fois
des Grands Boulevards haussmanniens puis
il y a des rues perpendiculaires et des
rues parallèles plus petites et le fait
notamment de changement aussi du sens de
circulation des pistes cyclables de la
rétrécissement de la voirie les
interventions de la police aujourd'hui
dans Paris ne sont pas de la même
manière qu'il y a 30 ou 40 ans chacun
peut le comprendre puisque chacun pourra
utiliser Paris de temps en temps on
constate effectivement ces changements
sont je ne porte d'opinion sur
évidemment ces changements et donc la du
maintien de l'ordre c'est choisir de
l'ordre républicain c'est comment on va
très vite aussi vite voire plus vite que
les personnes qui
ont décidé de se décomposer en petits
groupes à travers Paris mettre des feux
ici attaquer des bâtiments là brave
c'est donc pas une unité qui intervient
en moto c'est unité qui se déplace en
moto la bras même c'est la possibilité
d'utiliser les motos de même je réponds
si en partie à Monsieur le Maire il y a
des bras même sapeurs-pompiers il y a
des braves sapeurs-pompiers il y a des
pompiers toujours avec la braven qui
viennent éteindre et d'ailleurs c'est
souvent les personnes de la Bretagne qui
protègent les pompiers qui sont aussi
parmi les blessés que j'ai évoqué parce
qu'on s'en prend pas qu'aux policiers
aux gendarmes l'argument de l'extrême
gauche serait bon si jamais les
policiers gendarmes seraient une forme
de bande contre une autre bande qui est
très affrontement on s'en prend on s'en
prend aux pompiers quand il a faire quel
rapport avec les instructions que
pourrait donner à mise à l'intérieur
particulièrement
condamnés par l'extrême gauche donc
évidemment très bien que c'est tout ce
qui ressemble à l'autorité tout ce qui
ressemble à la République tout ce qui
ressemble à la République telle que nous
l'aimons depuis au mois de siècle qui
est attaqué par ces questions de dragon
et je ne comprends pas effectivement le
manque de ces condamnations donc Abraham
n'est pas une unités d'ailleurs moi
j'habite chacune et chacun pour monsieur
porte comme pour vous comme problème
monsieur Pouillet je sais que vous
l'avez fait allez voir la même vous
serez très bien reçue il y a aucun
problème passer une journée avec eux la
FP nous a demandé ils ont pu être avec
la brabaine Bfm l'a demandé ils ont pu
être moi-même j'ai vu que monsieur
bernadisse utilisé
le 1er avril pour dire qu'il avait été
invité mais on lui a dit chiche venez à
bras même il y a une manifestation
demain monsieur porte n'hésitez pas à
venir voir voir la bravem vous serez
vous serez vous serez bien vous serez
bienvenus vous serez bienvenus tant
qu'il est facile parfois de d'attaquer
personnellement les policiers à travers
un micro mais qui est plus difficile
d'aller leur serrer la main et d'aller
voir leur difficile travail sur la
question
de question la question la question de
Monsieur le Député alors j'ai oublié
votre nom monsieur le député parce que
vous avez beau me je vous vois pas
souvent dans mon département du Nord
mais je je vous avais censé censé
évoquer une proximité que nous n'avions
pas on ne ferait croire à personne de ce
député que je ne soutiens pas les
policiers les gendarmes vous ne ferez
quoi à personne par contre je me
souviens bien la campagne présidentielle
Madame Le Pen qui a mis voué au gémonie
publiquement devant tout le monde au
journal de 20h un policier du Service de
protection des personnalité qui en fait
n'en était pas un puisque c'était une
personne du rassemblement national qui
avait tirée par les jambes rappelez-vous
je crois un militante d'ailleurs
écologiste donc c'est sûr que s'il y a
quelqu'un qui se défaut sur les
policiers c'est bien Madame Le Pen et
son groupe politique c'est pas le
gouvernement de la République et sa
majorité qu'il les soutient vous ne
ferez croire à personne monsieur député
ce cas d'ailleurs je voudrais vous dire
Monsieur député que vous dites si je
peux me permettre des choses qui ne sont
pas vraies
il y a une différence entre le retrait
du service général le temps qu'une
enquête administrative ou judiciaire se
fasse et la suspension lorsque l'on dit
il est retiré de la voie publique vous
le savez bien ce n'est pas au lieu rôtir
sa qualité de policier de gendarme c'est
à dire que pendant le moment y compris
pour sa propre intégrité physique y
compris pour sa propre réputation
médiatique quand un policier ou un
gendarme et soupçonné d'avoir quelque
chose qui serait contraire à déontologie
ça peut arriver avouons-le qu'est-ce qui
se passe et bien on le met de côté en
attendant que la vérité soit faite c'est
exactement ce qui est arrivé au 2
gendarmes de Sainte-Soline qui ont tiré
LBD de leur quad ils ont été suspendus
de l'action d'ordre public mais ils
n'ont pas été suspendus de leur vie de
gendarmes et d'ailleurs l'iggn rend
cette semaine le rapport voilà donc ne
faites pas croire ce qui n'est pas vrai
ce serait d'abord une forme à mon avis
de respect envers des policiers et des
gendarmes de la
madame
guetter dites vous dites vous
n'empêcherez pas par les policiers de
gendarmes la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique vous avez
parfaitement raison le ministère de
l'Intérieur et ses agents n'ont pas à
avoir d'opinion sur les sujets de
manifestation d'ailleurs ça a été dit
une partie des policiers sont contre la
réforme des retraites contrairement à ce
qui était dit il travaille pas deux ans
de plus puisqu'on n'a pas bougé
catégorie active là aussi c'est une fake
news mais je reviens pas sur le sujet il
y a des policiers qui sont contre la
femme de retraite et qui encadrent les
réformes la contestation contre la
réforme des retraites il y a des gens
qui sont contre les propos que tiennent
notamment les personnes de votre famille
politique et qu'on fait des
manifestations les policiers et
protègent cette manifestation et c'est
tout à fait logique et c'est tout à fait
à leur honneur c'est bien la police de
la République c'est pas la police
évidemment la partie la partie la partie
politique moi mon opinion madame la
députée je n'ai pas à l'exprimer ou
orienter les services de police quel que
soit les mises à l'intérieur pour la
cause vous avez parfaitement raison ce
n'est pas par la police par la
gendarmerie n'empêche les causes de
s'exprimer ou les thèmes que vous voulez
défendre
d'être combattu c'est pas du tout
l'objet mais
avouez quand même que il y a un débat
philosophique qui est très intéressant
dans notre semaine indépendamment des
noms d'oiseaux ou effectivement de la
polémique sur les policiers ou les
gendarmes ce qui s'est passé j'entends
d'une partie de l'extrême gauche
l'argument suivant et vous l'avez dit
plusieurs fois plusieurs reprises de
façon différente
non j'entends une partie j'ai entendu
une partie de l'extrême gauche les
arguments suivants et vous l'avez
vous-même vous l'avez vous-même évoqué
non mais vous sentez pas visé mabrogl
mais même moi-même évoquer bien
vous dites il n'aurait pas fallu mettre
des policiers et des gendarmes parce que
vous savez que ce serait violent et
qu'après tout ce ne sont et que ce ne
sont que des biens
c'est très intéressant ça veut dire que
d'abord vous refusez le roi de propriété
personne ne dit que c'est pauvres
agriculteurs il y a des champs tout le
monde a foulé leur chant comme au
foulerait votre jardin si on fourrait
votre jardin je pense que vous
considérez que ce n'est pas tout à fait
je parle pas de vous madame guettez je
parle en général je reviendrai après sur
votre question je regarde sur votre
question mais c'est intéressant parce
que philosophiquement je pense que ça
sous-tend beaucoup de nos désaccords
vous dites il y aurait donc des
confrontations il y aura des
manifestants blessés puisque il y aura
de la violence et donc il faudrait pour
les biens pour des bassines pour des
trous
éventuellement pour d'autres biens il
faudrait pas y mettre des policiers des
gendarmes après tout ça a été dit tout à
l'heure à la cantonade c'était un trou
bon
non mais c'est pas bah oui c'est une
propriété privée alors après ça dépend
si on considère que la propriété c'est
du vol ou c'est pas du vol deuxièmement
il y a eu des décisions de justice le
rôle de la police gendarmerie c'est
d'appliquer les décisions de justice
c'est d'appliquer des sons de justice on
n'a pas à dire si le juge a eu raison ou
pas raison il y a eu des décisions de
justice les bassines c'était un outil
c'est un outil pour les agriculteurs
tout le monde oublie les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui mais c'est eux qui sont
harcelés pour une partie d'entre eux
pour une partie d'entre eux agriculteurs
ont été harcelés attaqués
allez on va écouter les réponses du
ministre s'il vous plaît
et l'objectif qui avait été défini
c'était non seulement de détruire les
bassines et les préparations des
bassines mais d'occuper le site par une
zone aux endroits et vous savez si
jamais les dirigeants correspondu
arriver les
Ultra gauche à Notre-Dame-des-Landes
avaient eu le même réaction que ce
gouvernement si il y aurait pas eu
Notre-Dame-des-Landes il y aurait pas eu
de contre-société et il y aurait pas eu
le désastre pour l'autorité de l'État
qui a été Notre-Dame-des-Landes parce
que Notre-Dame-des-Landes nourrit
d'autres contestations d'ultra gauche et
donc oui et oui les policiers et les
gendarmes sont là pour protéger les
biens et pas simplement les personnes et
pour faire respecter les décisions de
justice et ne nous appartient pas de
penser que notre opinion personnelle est
supérieure à décision de justice on peut
le penser une pétau on peut faire de la
politique pour changer les lois mais il
nous appartient pas de dire la décision
de justice était mauvaise par nature et
donc il ne faudrait pas puisque droit
manifester serait supérieur à tout il ne
faudrait pas que les policiers gendarmes
appliquent ces sons de justice les les
policiers gendarmes ont appliqué l'état
de droits ils ont appliqué des sessions
de justice pris par des juges
indépendants alors vous dites on a
oublié on n'a pas donné madame guetter
se reprend vos propos le statut
d'observateur à des observateurs
notamment à la à la LDH alors c'était un
drôle d'observateur la LDH puisqu'il a
attaqué l'arrêté qui empêchait les
transports d'armes de la préfète et que
le tribunal administratif de Poitiers
lui-même n'a pas reconnu le statut
d'observateur à la LDH donc vous nous
reprochez en fait d'appliquer l'édition
de justice si la justice avait considéré
que la LDH avait statue observateur on
l'aurait bien volontiers mais c'est un
observateur qui a appelé à manifester
malgré elle m'a fait ça sur interdite
qui a attaqué les arrêtés de transport
de drogue et par ailleurs si si elle a
appelé elle a appelé à se dire cette
manifestation et elle a elle a attaqué
les arrêtés de transport d'armes
d'interdiction de transport d'armes
c'est un drôle d'observateur qui dirait
qui attaquerait l'arrêté de transport
d'armes avouer que c'est pas très
pacifique et troisièmement le tribunal
administratif de Poitiers lui-même n'a
pas donné le statut d'observateur a
refusé donc nous avons appliqué ils sont
de justice si une décision de justice
avait donné le statut observateur à tel
ou tel association
nous l'aurions donné bien volontiers en
fait votre je trouve que la difficulté
c'est que Vous contestez le fait que la
police est gendarmerie qui met ça à
l'intérieur applique des décisions de
justice alors si le droit est mauvais
vous faites de la politique pour le
changer je l'ai bien compris mais pour
l'instant vous n'êtes pas majoritaire et
donc vous ne pouvez pas changer ce droit
ce droit pour la science s'applique à
tout le monde qui nous pèse ou qui nous
déplace je voudrais remercier Monsieur
cioti pour son soutien évidemment aux
forces de l'ordre
ben oui ben bien sûr il faut le dire
c'est un soutien un soutien à ce diafran
et massif alors s'il vous plaît vous
laissez répondre le ministre et après
les questions parce qu'on en a encore un
certain nombre
de même que je voulais se dire monsieur
Mendon sur son soutien aux forces de
l'ordre qui m'évoque comme Monsieur
sutile la question des activistes et
finalement c'est la question de Monsieur
Baudry également à la fin je répète le
droit tel que le ministère de
l'intérieur peut l'appliquer mais
l'intérieur il est pas là pour créer la
loi il est là pour appliquer la loi qui
a été votée par législateur et validé
par le Conseil constitutionnel et par
les décisions de justice qui en font
l'application par leur jurisprudence
aujourd'hui le ministre intérieur je le
répète ne peut pas procéder à des
interpellations de personnes sous
prétexte qu'il serait connu des services
de renseignement pour leur violence
réelle ou supposées ce n'est pas
possible voilà d'ailleurs contrairement
à ce que l'on dit c'est pas parce que on
dit qu'il y a 2200 personnes ultra
gauche et 1000 personnes de notre à
droite qui sont fichées s que ce sont
des personnes qui ont commis forcément
des choses qui sont au contraire au
droit ce sont des fiches de
renseignement et comme leur nom
l'indique ils permettent de faire du
deuxièmement et non pas de faire des
interpellations lorsqu'il y a un soupçon
lorsqu'il y a une possibilité qu'une
personne est commise une dégradation un
délit un crime que font les policiers
gendarmes ils interpellent les personnes
il le présente à l'officier de police
judiciaire qui agit sous l'autorité du
procureur de la République il le met en
garde à vue être en garde à vue c'est
pas être responsable de quelque chose
c'est qu'on vous soupçonne d'être
responsable de quelque chose ensuite la
mise en examen c'est quand ils indices
graves et concordants c'est pas dire
qu'on est responsable ça veut dire que
les indices graves et concordants et
être condamnés ça c'est un juge qui le
dit et c'est pas un service de prise de
le dire donc le travail des policiers
des gendarmes c'est quand il y a un
soupçon important c'est de prendre des
personnes les interpeller les mettre en
garde à vue les présenter au poker de la
République qui ensuite fait des
poursuites ou pas de poursuite mais
aujourd'hui je le dis pour le
législateur que vous êtes il n'y a pas
de possibilité pour les 16 Miss à
intérieures quand ils connaissent
quelqu'un de dangereux potentiellement
tant que c'est pas documenté sans que
c'est pas judiciarisé de l'interpeller
en amont je vous mets ceci à sagacité
évidemment du débat parlementaire
c'était bien une question très
compliquée mais c'est une question avec
laquelle le mystère d'intérieur souhaite
ne pas débattre puisque lui ne fait
qu'appliquer la loi monsieur Vico bon
moi je suis toujours
je suis toujours étonné du signe égal
qu'on peut mettre entre la violence fait
par certains et les policiers parce
qu'il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de signe égal parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'un côté ceux qui auraient un
combat légitime et de l'autre qui aurait
juste le droit de la force il y en a qui
ont le droit de la force et l'autre qui
n'ont pas le droit de la force donc
quand bien même il y aurait des
violences entre des policiers des
gendarmes et des manifestants combien de
policiers individuellement
n'utiliseraient pas de façon
proportionnée la force et dans ces
cas-là je suis d'accord avec vous il
faut les sanctionner j'en ai sanctionner
111 en 2021 et une centaine en 2022 sur
250 000 policiers et gend sur 250000
policiers et gendarmes mais vous avez
géré une police municipale vu que ces
questions de sécurité vous le savez
extrêmement bien quand bien même il y
aurait cela il y a ceux qui ont la force
légitime donnée par l'État donné par le
droit et ce qui ne l'ont pas donc quand
vous mettez quand vous dites il y aurait
ce signe égal d'où elles viennent la
violence de kelvienne non il faut
refuser déjà se débat la France donc
elle vienne c'est pas la violence d'où
qu'elle vienne les policiers gendarmes
ne font que répliquer à des personnes
qui sont violents ce n'est jamais eux
qui en premier iraient dans les rues et
à Sainte Soline trouverait des personnes
dans un champ et les attaqueraient c'est
en réplique est-ce que la réplique est
proportionnée est-ce que la stratégie la
botte une question intéressante bien
évidemment mais ce n'est jamais eux qui
lui qui l'utilisent je voudrais dire
monsieur Vico par ailleurs qui a
beaucoup de choses qui sont extrêmement
évoquées vous parlez des vidéos et vous
parler notamment de ces gendarmes qui
auraient fait la leçon aux policiers
elle date de 2020 monsieur Vico cette
vidéo même Libération a fait une
vérification et à publier le fait que
c'était une vidéo qui n'avait rien à
voir avec donc je pense que l'un de nos
problèmes pensez pourtant public l'un de
nos problèmes c'est que on essaye pas
d'avoir un minimum je veux dire là pour
le coup d'action je dis pas d'honnêteté
parce que je connais votre netteté mais
là on donne de la braven elle a pas été
concerné par cette vidéo en 2022 voilà
donc il faut le redire c'est 2020 et je
remercie le journal Libération de
l'avoir de l'avoir évoqué sur la
question de Madame faussillon bon je
rappelle d'ailleurs je sais qu'elle
connaît pas les oeuvres complètes de
Jacques Chirac c'est d'ailleurs un
problème mais en 1988
intellectuel voilà donc à moins que
Jacques Chirac était d'extrême droite ce
qui ce qui est bon même monsieur Ruffin
si tu es Jacques Chirac récemment donc
parlez-en avec lui je sais qu'à une
place c'est compliqué en ce moment mais
n'hésitez pas à écouter monsieur F1 donc
je pense que ça ce sujet n'est pas le
bon sur Madame regolle
madame madame
rogol vous évoquez
les menaces et les intimidations
est-ce que est-ce que vous pouvez
écouter le ministre parce que on perd le
temps pour vos questions futures voilà
bon c'est bon oui bah si vous vous
taisiez tous vous verrez pas aller dans
les autres monsieur le ministre
allez
madame Google évoque
évoque les exactions et les et les
insultes ou les menaces que reçoivent
madame
bien évidemment d'ailleurs le 28 mars
elle a eu
elle a eu un échange avec notamment je
crois la directrice générale
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts avec mon
directeur de cabinet à plusieurs
reprises elle a d'ailleurs été protégée
par les gendarmes lors de son
avance dans son action militante
totalement légitime dans le sud-ouest de
la France
oui mais les gendarmes ont peur vous
avez raison les gendarmes ont peur mais
merci merci de le reconnaître les
gendarmes ont aussi peur c'est des
pervers de famille et donc oui on
protège madame tourdelier comme on a
prêté Monsieur Mélenchon qu'on protège
toutes les personnes qui se sentent
menacées réellement donc c'est un sujet
après il est possible qu'il est possible
on protège des élus de gauche de la
dupesse d'ailleurs y compris par des
personnes usdlp je tiens évidemment
secrète mais c'est normal voilà il
existe parfois des gens qui veulent pas
être protégés par des policiers ça c'est
aussi ça c'est aussi possible donc oui
madame tourdelier
physiquement et oralement et que c'est
ces insultes et ses agressions sont
inacceptables et que autant que faire ce
peu les parlementaires les hommes et
femmes politiques sont protégés par la
police de la République bien évidemment
on a protégé madame Coffin par exemple à
Paris voilà quelques mois parce qu'elle
était l'objet d'un Sud et de menace
inacceptable j'en suis parfaitement pas
d'accord j'ai eu un échange non échange
et Madame Rousseau qui d'ailleurs l'a
rendu public pour le fait
qu'effectivement on est tout à fait
attentif que les actions les violences
sont de oui bien sûr de l'ultra droit de
l'extrême droite c'était quand même un
panneau qui m'avait aussi interpellé qui
je viens d'échange personnel c'est le
cas aussi d'autres d'autres
parlementaires donc il y a pas de il y a
pas de difficulté pour le reconnaître
bien évidemment vous me posez la
question madame rigole par ailleurs de
service de secours qui avait été prévu
j'aurais redire mais c'est très
important qu'en droit le droit je parle
à des législateurs c'est que les
organisateurs de manifestations sont les
responsables de services de secours mais
devant l'absence de réponse répétée de
ces organisateurs il y a eu madame
regolle 13 véhicules du 10 qui étaient
mobilisé c'est-à-dire 41
sapeurs-pompiers trois équipes médicales
avec 3 médecins de la gendarmerie
nationale 5 murs deux hélicoptères a du
SMUR à la gendarmerie national donc pour
des gens pour des gendarmes pour des
préfets qui avaient interdit à
manifestation et qui rappelait aux
organisateurs leur responsabilité avouer
que c'était à dispositif très conséquent
madame Guitton madame madame madame
madame
monsieur guython excusez-moi
monsieur Guiton excusez-moi c'était pas
une attaque personnelle monsieur guython
vous avez raison de dire que il manque
des policiers et des gendarmes mobiles
dans nos territoires je moi-même évoqué
la loi l'ovni consacre vous dites il n'y
a que 4 CRS et cette jambe mobile bah
écoutez c'est déjà pas si mal 4 CRS mais
vous devez préciser que c'est des CRS
sur le modèle de la crs8 c'est un des
équipes à 200 policiers et pas sans même
moi c'est à peu près 80 unités de force
mobile donc c'est des CRS qui en fait on
compte pour le au moins le double voir
le trip c'est 200 par unité de CRS et
ils sont extrêmement mobiles on voit
bien que ce qui nous manque c'est la
mobilité des mobiles pardon de le dire
comme ça on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler et cette gendarmes c'est unité
de gendarmes mobiles c'est exactement ce
que souhaitait les forces et seront
prêtes des cette année nous avons cette
demi-ufm de gendarmerie mobile pour le
mois de juin et cette autonomie ufm
seront prêtes pour le mois d'octobre
pour le mois d'octobre il y a trois
unités de CRS qui sont totalement créées
en France et la quatrième arrive au mois
de mars que nous ne perdons pas de temps
vous dites pourquoi vous l'avez pas fait
depuis 2017 d'abord en 2017 nous avons
augmenté les unités dans les CRS pour
monter à quatre sections parce qu'avant
de passer à d'autres CRS ou à d'autres
gendarmes mobiles il faut d'abord
remonter les effectifs qui n'étaient pas
à disposition ensuite il y a un choix
stratégique qui a été fait en 2017 et on
l'a encore vu ce matin enfin hier soir
par l'interpellation de la DGSI de cette
personne qui s'avérait pourrait aurait
pu projeter une attente d'attentat on a
augmenté de 4000 le nombre de policiers
de gendarmes à la DGSI et dans les
restaurants territoriaux parce que la
menace de 2017 monsieur Guitton c'était
la menace terroriste nous avons déjoué
une quarantaine d'attentats depuis 2017
et nous le faisons parce que nous avons
des services de renseignement en un oui
c'était le renseignement parce que ma
story c'était plus important que leur
public et en deux bien sûr c'est dans le
public et donc c'est pour ça que nous y
mettons les moyens madame Martin évoqué
l'interdiction de la manifestation je
vais quand même Martin que non il est
faux de dire que dans les Deux-Sèvres
les manifestations ont tout été
interdite Amel elle a été autorisée et
il y a eu des milliers de personnes je
crois entre 5000 et 6000 personnes Amel
Amel mais la manifestation contre les
bassines pacifiquement était possible
Amel Amel c'est à côté de s'insoline en
face des bassines oui vu ce qui s'était
passé il y a 6 mois elle était entre
guillemets interdite et là je vous ai
dit que quand on dit on a le droit de
manifester même c'est interdit non on
n'a pas le droit de manifester quand
c'est interdit l'application de
déclaration
l'obligation de déclaration préalable du
manifestation est prévue depuis 1935 et
mis dans le code de sécurité intérieure
c'est l'article L 211 est suivant
organiser une manifestation non déclarée
ou interdite constitue un délit au sens
d'articles 431 du code pénal puni de six
mois d'emprisonnement participer à une
manifestation interdite constitue une
infraction qu'on ce qui est puni d'une
amende le quatrième classe et constituer
un attroupement ou un rassemblement de
personnes soient République
susceptible de trouver l'ordre public
les gens disent commenté pardon parfois
on a fait des interpellations
préventives sans aucun délit pardon mais
si vous pensez que le code [__] est
mal rédigé rédigez-le différemment vous
êtes des législateurs l'article 431-3 du
code pénal d'ailleurs je vous encourage
à regarder qui a créé cet article 431-3
du code pénal vous y verrez
politiquement que c'est intéressant
constitue à notre constitue un
attroupement où tout rassemblement de
personnes sur la voie publique ou dans
un lieu public susceptible de trouver
leur droit public permet en effet aux
forces de police de pouvoir interpeller
les personnes voilà donc si vous pensez
mesdames et messieurs députés que le
droit est mal fait puisque moi
j'applique le droit n'hésitez pas à
changer le droit mais ce n'est pas à moi
de le faire
je pense que j'ai quasiment terminé
peut-être pour Monsieur maddesse pour
les parlementaires et pour les élus
c'est pas moi de juger les
parlementaires je sais pas la police des
assemblées mais je vous encourage à
l'évoquer effectivement j'ai vu des
choses extrêmement choquantes sur
l'Abraham je pense que j'ai répondu à
monsieur porte et mon invitation tiens
c'est taux de matin n'hésitez pas à
venir avec grand plaisir si c'est pas
demain ça peut être un autre moment et
je crois que j'ai répondu et pour
Monsieur monsieur projet je pense que
j'ai aussi répondu à la question alors
il me reste 19 intervenants et très peu
de temps donc je vous invite à la
brièveté et j'aimerais que vous puissiez
vous exprimer en une minute madame
Marietta carrément Lee
bon on va pas changer de règle mais on
va aller assez vite monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre
c'est bon le ministre un état des lieux
des pratiques et des doctrines du
maintien de l'ordre a été aussi réalisé
par l'Assemblée nationale lors de la
précédente législature la liberté donc
de manifester est un endroit fondamental
on la rappelait il doit être aussi
concilier avec la nécessaire
préservation de l'ordre public alors
plusieurs enjeux ont été identifiés ils
restent toujours identifiables je
rappellerai deux trois le premier est
celui de la formation dont on n'a pas
parlé aujourd'hui une formation de base
relative au maintien de l'ordre et
commune à tous les agents qui doit être
assurés il faut aussi
reprofessionnaliser les forces
spécialisées en distinguant justement
les techniques de déploiement en cas de
violence urbaine et celle de déploiement
face à des rassemblements des
manifestations il y a aussi un schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre qui doit
être actualisé aussi souvent que
possible et faire aussi l'objet d'une
concertation avec les syndicats de
police mais pas seulement des grands
syndicats des organisations susceptibles
d'appeler manifester et les
organisations en de droit liberté comme
défenseur de droits Commission nationale
consultative de droits de l'homme alors
il y a plusieurs éléments que je voulais
rappeler puisque le ministre sur le site
différent points la formation
l'actualisation du schéma la discussion
avec les organisations demande syndicale
et associative le contrôle interne et
externe lorsqu'il y a des dérives en
formation du Parlement lien avec le
monde universitaire et les transparence
quelle chaîne aujourd'hui vos priorités
comment vous comptez intégrer ces
éléments et attendez-vous transmettre un
calendrier de mise en oeuvre des actions
que vous entendez aujourd'hui mener
merci Madame blonde Broca
pour les côtoyer depuis de nombreuses
années dans leur mission quotidien dans
leur difficulté aussi je suis toujours
impressionné par le calme et le
discernement dont nos gendarmes des
policiers font preuve dans des
situations conflictuelles face à des
individus ou des groupes irrespectueux
agressifs voire très violent et les
images et vidéos que vous nous avez
projetées sont terriblement éloquantes
et révélatrices de ces scènes de
guérilla urbaine la très grande majorité
de nos concitoyens respectent nos forces
de l'ordre respectent la mission de ces
fans des de ses hommes mission qui est
avant tout de nous protéger et de
protéger notre République et ses
institutions je rappelle ici au passage
le sondage CSA du 28 mars dernier 85%
des Français condamnent les violences
contre les forces de l'ordre on déplaise
à certains qui se plaisent d'ailleurs à
attiser ces désordres et c'est un
euphémisme l'outrage l'outrans et la
provocation sont devenues le beurre de
certains d'apprentis cinéaste qui trouve
leur 15 minutes de gloire dans le nombre
de vues générés par leurs exactions ou
celle de leur kobile géants
certains médias qui ne cherchent plus à
informer mais à espérer un affrontement
débordement ou même de certaines figures
médiatiques qui tentent généreusement
leur micro à des activistes des factieux
qui ne sont rien des manifestants
portant des revendications et vous avez
rappelé monsieur le ministre que les
rassemblements sans ultra gauche se
déroulent sans heurts
d'ailleurs leur cause d'autant plus
légitime si les hommes ne l'ont pas
entendu monsieur le ministre ne
croyez-vous pas qu'il est grand temps
d'instaurer une charte déontologique du
citoyen qui régule ses relations avec
les forces de l'ordre les élus les
enseignants les administrations et avec
tous les citoyens afin que chaque
Français prenne conscience de ses
devoirs de citoyens pour que nous
puissions être une nation unie merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la police doit être responsable
devant l'état les citoyens et leur
représentants elle doit faire l'objet
d'un contrôle externe efficace cette
citation est extraite du code européen
d'éthique de la police validée par le
Conseil de l'Europe et par la France ce
code précise aussi je cite que les
pouvoirs publics doivent mettre en place
des procédures effectives et impartiales
de recours contre la police comment ces
procédures pourraient-elles être
impartial alors que l'IGPN dépend
directement du directeur général de la
police nationale la reconstruction de la
confiance entre la police et la
population ne se décrète pas elle repose
sur la transparence et celle-ci est plus
que jamais abîmée à l'heure où le
Conseil de l'Europe l'ONU la Ligue des
droits de l'homme le Syndicat des
Avocats de France le Syndicat de la
magistrature Amnesty internationale
alerte sur la brutalité de votre
maintien du désordre pourquoi ne pas
prendre exemple sur le modèle
britannique pourquoi ne pas laisser le
rôle à la Défenseur des droits en lui
conférant un service spécifique comme le
demande de nombreuses associations
merci
beaucoup madame Marie-France
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on constate un phénomène
émotier recrudescence qui modifie dans
sa structure le déroulement des cortèges
de manifestations dans les villes de
France la stratégie manifestante est
traversée du fait de groupe de casseurs
par une logique d'affrontement ces
manifestants violents vont ton contact
et attaquent les policiers l'objectif de
ces individus radicalisés de pousser à
bout le policier jusqu'à provoquer chez
lui une réponse mal proportionnée il
faut donc adapter la stratégie des
forces de l'ordre à cette réalité car
cette confrontation brutale ne fait
qu'exaspérer le degré de violence de
part et d'autre et ouvre le champ à tous
les débordements il n'apparaît pas
soutenable de se satisfaire de se
détournement de mise en oeuvre du droit
fondamental de manifester ni davantage
de laisser santagoniser une partie de la
population contre une autre l'atteinte
au maintien de l'ordre par ces groupes
factieux devraient être systématiquement
et effectivement réprimé pour dissuader
tout passage à l'acte violent contre les
forces de l'ordre à Paris 76% des
individus interpellés depuis le 15 mars
à l'occasion du mouvement social n'ont
pas été poursuivies parmi les individus
poursuivi certains ont vu leur procès
renvoyaient une date ultérieure ont été
relaxées les policiers interpellent mais
il n'y a pas de poursuite pénale
consécutives c'est cette rupture de la
réponse pénale qui fait le lit de cette
impunité ultra-violente dirigée contre
la police monsieur le ministre
pensez-vous que la communication entre
les services de votre ministère et ceux
du ministère de la justice pourrait être
amélioré au fin d'assurer un meilleur
suivi entre les interpellations
policières et les poursuites judiciaires
corrélatives je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Thomas Rudigoz
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous avez rappelé les
actions violentes qui ont été menées
contre les représentations de notre
République de nos institutions vous avez
rappelé ce qui s'est passé à la mairie
du 4ème arrondissement de Lyon je tiens
aussi à ajouter ce qui s'est passé
contre un poste de police municipale
dans le premier arrondissement de Lyon
qui a été attaqué avec une grande
violence je tiens à rappeler l'incendie
du centre des impôts de Bron ou s'est
rendu monsieur le ministre des comptes
publics Gabriel Attal en ma présence et
en présence également du député de la
circonscription monsieur Vincent des à
chaque fois c'était signé c'était
l'ultra gauche c'était les anarchistes
je tiens d'ailleurs à souligner que si
les représentants de la Ville de Lyon
écologiste ont dénoncé condamné à chaque
fois ces violences ils ne les ont jamais
cité et il faut citer les auteurs comme
nous citons l'ultra-droite quand elle
est à l'origine de violence et
d'exactions il faut citer la
ultra gauche vous avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre les moyens qui sont mis pour
suivre ces groupuscules les
renseignements territoriaux même la DGSI
néanmoins monsieur le ministre nous en
avions parlé lors de la loop me j'avais
pu défendre un amendement dans ce sens
quel moyen quelle mesure supplémentaire
comptez-vous mettre en œuvre pour
renforcer la surveillance et la
neutralisation de ces groupuscules
d'ultra gauche je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Benjamin Lucas
merci pour ce matin c'était l'audition
Paris Match vous savez le poids des mots
le choc des photos même si le ministre
de l'Intérieur les monts ont un sens
alors terroriste intellectuel la
Défenseur des droits qui appelle à la
des escalades et c'est l'arme du
non-respect des principes déontologiques
terroriste intellectuel le commissaire
au droit de l'Homme du Conseil de
l'Europe excusé du peu qui rappelle que
manifester est un droit fondamental qui
doit être protégé terroriste
intellectuel le rapporteur spécial des
Nations Unies qui s'inquiètent d'un
usage excessif de la force en France
terroriste intellectuel le président
Biden et son porte-parole à la Maison
Blanche terroriste intellectuel votre
propre ministre de l'éducation nationale
qui déclarait à raison en 2020 que il y
avait dans la classe politique française
un grand déni sur les violences
policières terroristes intellectuelle
vous-même qui avait reconnu avoir
sanctionné 111 cas de violence policière
preuve qu'elles existent bien puis on a
eu évidemment le choc des photos avec un
joli PowerPoint style McKinsey mais ici
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur on
est à l'Assemblée nationale on doit
avoir un débat sérieux et démocratique
sur le maintien de l'ordre vous avez
raison il n'y a pas de signe égal entre
toutes les violences parce que
vous n'êtes pas responsable vous
personnellement des Black Blocs qui
viennent et nous condamnons évidemment
toutes les violences cassées des
vitrines sans prendre au bien et aux
personnes dans des manifestations en
revanche vous êtes responsables de la
police républicaine qui parce qu'elle a
le monopole légitime de la violence et
de la force à plus de responsabilités et
plus de devoirs à l'égard de la société
c'est de cette responsabilité là que
nous aurions aimé que vous vous
expliquez aujourd'hui vous avez évoqué
des mots et des images vous avez oublié
bien des faits c'est centaines de garder
à vue qui ressort sans aucune poursuite
preuve de leur innocence c'est mutiler
ces manifestants dans le coma monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur vous avez
esquivé ce matin vos responsabilités
merci Madame saratanzili
[Musique]
recommande un maintien de l'ordre
uniforme et de qualité sur le territoire
mais également afin de garantir leur
propre sécurité
ma question est donc la suivante quelle
mesure sont mises en oeuvre par votre
ministère afin de garantir
l'attractivité du métier de CRS et de
gendarmes mobiles comment est organisé
la formation continue nos forces de
l'ordre et donc elle délai ouvrira le
centre de formation prévu par la locmie
enfin ma dernière question porte sur la
conciliation entre maintien de l'ordre
habituel et engagement des forces de
sécurité intérieure sur les grands
événements sportifs à venir dans notre
pays comment votre ministère
s'organise-t-il afin d'assurer la
sécurité de tous partout sur le
territoire en parallèle de ces grandes
manifestations je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en dehors des événements ce qui
me pose problème c'est plus le manque
d'anticipation du caractère violent de
ces manifestations et je voudrais mettre
l'accent sur l'importance du
renseignement dans cette anticipation en
effet pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas eu de
renseignements sur l'état d'esprit des
manifestants ou s'il y en a eu pourquoi
n'ont-ils pas été prises en compte au
cours de ma carrière dans la police
nationale j'ai en tant que patron du
renseignement dans plusieurs
départements maintes fois pu mesurer
l'importance de ce travail essentiel aux
forces de police et de gendarmerie qui
sont sur le terrain là à Sainte Soline
de véritables guerriers héros armés de
Hachette de couteaux d'engins
incendiaires sont passés sous les radars
pourtant vos services de renseignement
sont vos yeux et vos oreilles là vous
avez été aveugle et sourd on sait que
parfois le laisser faire peut cacher une
volonté de discréditer un mouvement je
n'ose croire que cela a été le cas à
Sainte Soline pour faire passer au
second plan la question de la réforme
des retraites et ainsi retourner
l'opinion la gestion du maintien de
l'ordre est un exercice difficile
l'anticipation et l'analyse prospective
sont absolument indispensables si l'on
veut s'y parvenir pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre ne pas utiliser les moyens
d'information et de renseignements qui
sont
Monsieur Jean-François Coulomme
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on préambule en mai 68 le
préfet de police de Paris Maurice
Grimaud écrit une lettre policiers
frapper un manifestant tombé à terre
c'est se frapper soi-même d'autres temps
d'autres mœurs
cette époque laisse le souvenir de
manifestation massive dont les dégâts
humains resteront bien moins que ceux
infligés aux manifestants de ces
dernières semaines tandis que les dégâts
matériels de Mai 68 furent eux bien plus
conséquent ainsi votre doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre a changé au début
lors des premières manifestations contre
la loi retraite nos gardiens de la paix
assuraient leurs services avec
discernement tempérance et leur présence
en marge de cortège les positionner
essentiellement comme des agents du bon
fonctionnement logistique des défilés
montrant ainsi que le maintien de
l'ordre et liberté de manifester pouvait
cohabiter pacifiquement que s'est-il
ensuite passé pour que le ministre de la
police dérivent sur un schéma de
maintien de l'ordre où l'utilisation
d'armes de guerre et d'engins mutilant
deviennent désormais la norme créant
ainsi le chaos et la mise en danger des
policiers comme des manifestants combien
de vie humaine policiers comme
manifestants êtes-vous prêt à risquer
pour des poubelles ou des trous dans la
terre vous détenez les clés de la
scalade et de la désescalade quel
bénéfice politique espérez vous tirer de
cette mise en confrontation
déraisonnable de nos concitoyens
policiers comme manifestants quels sont
les intérêts que votre gouvernement a
défendre que vous engagiez des
stratégies de confrontation
potentiellement létales dénoncée par
toutes les organisations internationales
et des droits de l'homme merci Madame
Mathilde Jonquières
le maintien de l'ordre est essentiel au
bon fonctionnement de notre société et à
la préservation de certains de nos
droits fondamentaux comme le droit de
manifester en évitant les débordements
on parle souvent des violences
policières et je ne remet pas en cause
le fait qu'il puisse y avoir parfois des
comportements individuels violents mais
il ne faut pas tomber dans le piège de
la démo de la démagogie et réduire les
forces de l'ordre à ses seuls
comportement qui entachent un travail du
quotidien celui de protéger nos
concitoyens il est toujours évoqué les
trains en retard mais jamais ceux qui
arrivent en avance je rappelle ainsi
qu'en 2021 sur 250000 policiers
gendarmes 111 ont été sanctionnés pour
usage disproportionné de la force mon
propos n'est pas de légitimer la
violence bien au contraire je la
condamne fermement mais il est important
à mon sens de relativiser et souligner
la majorité des policiers et des
gendarmes qui ont à cœur de bien faire
leur travail il semble aujourd'hui
essentiel de renouer les biens entre la
société civile et les forces de l'ordre
pour permettre à nos concitoyens de
mieux comprendre un métier mise à mal
ces dernières années comprend les enjeux
et les difficultés la société civile a
beaucoup à apprendre des forces de
l'ordre et vice versa protéger c'est
aussi comprendre les besoins et y
répondre nous ne pourrons guérir les
mots de notre société sans le dialogue
et la compréhension ainsi Monsieur le
Ministre que prévoit le gouvernement
pour réconcilier la société civile avec
les forces de l'ordre ce sujet d'autant
plus important que les manifestations
sont de plus en plus gangrinées par des
groupuscules violents et s'ajoutent à
cela l'usage des nouvelles technologies
ainsi que la montée de la défiance de la
société civile tout cela contribue à la
pérennisation d'un climat violent qu'il
convient désamorcer ceci passe en
premier lieu par une meilleure formation
des forces de l'ordre que prévoit le
gouvernement concernant ce sujet merci
merci
monsieur le Président moi je voulais
simplement vous poser la question de
savoir s'il y a un concours avait été
ouvert à savoir celui qui prononcerait
le plus souvent le mot ultra gauche
pendant ces deux heures de débat et puis
rappeler quand même que la police
républicaine que nous chérissons tous
que nous chérissons tous en cadre les
libertés publiques vous le savez
monsieur le ministre elle ne les
supprime pas évidemment au contraire
elle les garantit et l'ordre est un
conciliateur des libertés et cette tâche
et les immenses devant vous donc vous
apportez vous faites un constat constat
il nous désole tous parce que nous
sommes dans un malaise qui nous
préoccupe
il y a une déstabilisation qui nous fait
peur nous croyons à la police
républicaine et nous voulons la
sauvegarder alors vous avez apporté des
réponses dans dans un slide sur les
réponses de l'État moi je voulais
simplement vous poser la question de la
formation parce que ça me paraît tout à
fait essentiel et je le dis sans malice
parce que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
les forces de police et de gendarmerie
mais il me semble que nous avons
accéléré la formation est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que il nous faut rattraper
cela j'ai entendu dire que le cours sur
les libertés publiques disparaissaient
des écoles de police ça me paraît tout à
fait important de les rétablir si tel et
tel cas et je voulais vous poser cette
question
vous avez pu entendre de 28 questions 8
ne pourront pas être posées par nos
collègues compte tenu de l'audition qui
est organisé au Sénat on aura 11 heures
je demande de répondre à ces questions
et le cas échéant on vous réentendra
dans les prochaines semaines pour poser
les autres questions avec priorité au
collègues qui n'ont pas pu poser les
heures
merci monsieur le Président évidemment
je suis à disposition comme vous le
souhaitez du Parlement pour toute
audition et notamment prolonger celle-ci
peut-être
sur les questions même l'euro sur
finalement la suite judiciaire donc
Madame Laurent je vous encourage à faire
inviter monsieur le garde des sceaux
parce que il pourra mieux que moi vous
répondre activité ces services tenez
peut-être les les chiffres totaux depuis
le 16 mars
1191 individus ont été interpellés
1169 ont été placés en garde à bus
c'est-à-dire sous l'autorité d'un EPG et
du parquet
193 individus ont été déférés
c'est-à-dire un taux déferlement de
16,5%, 50 individus ont fait l'objet
d'une reconnaissance
de culpabilité de la part de même ou
d'une CBJ c'est ce que vous appelez la
présentation quelques mois après 68
individus ont fait l'objet d'une
convocation devant le délégué du
procureur de la République
4h46 individus concernés sont par des
enquêtes judiciaires en préliminaires et
18 personnes sur ces individus
interpellés étaient des fichiers s voilà
ce qui fait statistique assez important
18 sur le petit millier que j'ai évoqué
donc après moi il m'appartient pas de
commenter la réponse pénale je constate
quand même qu'un taux de défairement de
16,5% des n'est pas un petit taux de
déferlement voilà contrairement à ce
qu'on peut ici ou là entendre
j'entends la question de Madame karamoly
il y a d'autres questions qui se posent
sur la question de la formation
l'information d'échange avec les
manifestants ou avec les organisations
on peut toujours améliorer la
coopération d'information qu'on a avec
ici les journalistes là des observateurs
etc c'est tout à fait vrai je constate
aussi que des journalistes ont été pris
à partie lors de ces manifestations
certains ont été blessés notamment ce
photographe de Sud-Ouest à Sainte-Soline
je pense ça nous a tous beaucoup touchés
il a il a il a été il était pas du côté
des gendarmes si j'ose dire mais il a dû
se réfugier du côté des gendarmes il y
en a d'ailleurs été blessé nous avons
proposé à la défenseur de droit de venir
quand elle le souhaitait évidemment par
exemple au PC qui est le PC général de
la préfecture de police elle a fait
savoir qu'elle pouvait pas venir la
semaine dernière mais elle viendra ce
jeudi donc c'est une très bonne chose et
j'encourage une nouvelle fois si vous le
souhaitez personnellement tout les
parlementaires que politique s'est passé
une journée demain avec les forces de
l'ordre pour se rendre compte de visu à
la fois la disproportion de la force si
vous le pensez vous la violence qui qui
subissent effectivement c'est toujours
plus plus difficile sur le sur le
terrain améliorer l'information et
notamment la question la formation sur
qu'est-ce qu'on dit aux manifestants sur
les sommations ou sur les sorties leur
des nazes ou des manifestations qui
peuvent dégénérer les outils
technologiques dont ce dont le ministère
à l'intérieur demain nous permettront de
le faire notamment en celles broadcast
c'est-à-dire le message que recevrait
sur votre téléphone qui vous dira la
sortie place de l'Opéra ici ou attention
des individus violents sont présents il
faut sortir voilà oui ça s'appelle les
sommations aujourd'hui on le fait par
haut parleur ce qui évidemment pas très
pas très efficace lorsqu'il y a du monde
lorsque du monde qui crie par exemple
voilà la deuxième des choses
que je voudrais évoquer peut-être pour
Monsieur Benjamin Lucas mais je vois que
Monsieur Benjamin Lucas est parti bon de
là où il est doit nous doit nous
entendre et si Monsieur Bolloré monsieur
Biden je savais pas que côté ces
références culturelles et politiques moi
je me permets de lui citer France Inter
ça vous surprendra peut-être d'ailleurs
et Bernard Cazeneuve est à écouter ce
matin
il a dit des choses importantes et
d'ailleurs il a été ministre de
l'Intérieur vous le savez au moment de
l'affaire de Sylvain c'était Premier
ministre mis à l'intérieur moment de la
loi el khomri gouvernement que vous
souteniez à l'époque non non mais je
voulais je vous laisse entre nups il y a
pas de pas de problème à propos de LFI
monsieur Cazeneuve c'est Monsieur
Cazeneuve je vois pas que je sois
attaquer l'ultra gauche je voudrais
vraiment pas être monsieur Cazeneuve a
dit ce matin
non on peut citer Bernard Cazeneuve sans
être traité de fasciste
on savait
on savait que c'était la partie de
l'outrance bon évidemment il parle de la
France insoumise je me sens pas
d'ailleurs dire des choses comme ça
maintenant c'est parti
maintenant cette partie de l'insulte il
paraît que c'est la gauche ce n'est pas
celle la gauche la gauche c'est le parti
de ceux qui considèrent que quiconque ne
pense pas comme eux doivent être
respectés moi je combats et les filles
en raison des orientations qu'il a
poussent à s'exprimer comme il est de le
rappeler à propos notamment des
violences je n'attends rien de je sais
comment ils sont structurés je sais ce
qu'ils sont capables je ne suis pas
chacun je ne suis pas choqué je suis
concerné car j'ai une autre idée de ce
qu'est la politique notre pays quand un
parlementaire met sous son pied un
ballon a été figé d'un ministre
expliquant que ce ministre rien assassin
cela suscite chez moi à profond des
goûts ce n'est pas la conception
républicaine et démocrates que j'ai
voilà donc je ne sais je ne pourrais pas
à Monsieur Lucas que ce que répond
monsieur Cazeneuve je ne serai je ne
serai mieux dire voilà effectivement un
des propos de bon sens et qui rappelle
que effectivement il y a évidemment une
gauche républicaine démocrate qui
respecte des forces de l'ordre dans ce
pays monsieur Coulomme vous avez fait
une j'espère que je prononce bien votre
nom vous avez fait vous avez fait un
écoutez-moi
allez allez on termine l'audition on est
encore quelques minutes et on a encore
quelques réponses à entendre allez
monsieur Colom et dit en 68 vous avez
dit une phrase qui est extraordinaire
monsieur vous avez dit en 68
madame rogol vous écoutez monsieur le
ministre comme tout le monde
en 68
monsieur Coulomme en 68 vous avez dit
qu'il y avait pas eu de bilans moins
importants que ceux de la vous savez
qu'il y a eu cette mort 68 monsieur
Colom un commissaire de police est si
manifestant c'est qu'il y a eu 2000
blessés dont 200 graves dont certains
sont restés handicapés à vie c'est
comparaison de ce que l'homme et son
insultantes pour les morts de Mai 68 qui
soit du côté des manifestants ou du côté
des services de police cette comparaison
est profondément insultante par ailleurs
allez par ailleurs par ailleurs je veux
évoquer évidemment les questions de
formation qui ont été évoquées on a
rallongé grâce d'ailleurs à la loi qu'on
a voté pour une grande partie de
l'hémicycle la formation des policiers
des gendarmes qui font dans mes 4 mois
de plus c'est évidemment le cas des
policiers et des gendarmes dans le
public évidemment il n'y a pas de remise
en cause des cours madame la députée je
veux dire que le centre de formation
s'ouvre au début de l'année 2024 celui
de Villeneuve-Saint-Georges et je veux
dire évidemment que la formation et
c'est un grand objectif des policiers
des gendarmes de maintien de l'ordre
sont très importants la difficulté que
nous avons c'est tant qu'il y a beaucoup
de mobilisations de ces politiciens nous
prenons sur le temps de formation ce qui
évidemment pose un problème à la fois de
repos mais aussi d'efficacité et c'est
évidemment à ne pas à ne pas remettre en
cause pour faire vite le maintien de
l'ordre demain et les unités de force
mobile c'est trois choses un tiers
d'action quel que soit ces actions de
maintien de l'ordre un tiers de repos un
tiers de formation et c'est ce que nous
devons réussir à faire avec les ondes
unités de force mobile qui ont été créés
de façon supplémentaire sur l'alliance
entre société civile et police je pense
que je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure sur le
travail du nouveau schéma du match de
Lord comme sur le travail de mise sur la
sécurité civile le conseil de
déontologie que nous allons mettre en
place et l'action de recherche qu'on
doit davantage faire au ministère de
l'Intérieur je veux quand même dire
puisque tout le monde aussi des sondages
sur la réforme des retraites et que
personne ne les conteste que malgré tout
le battage médiatique que nous avons
connue cette Français sur dix continue à
se tenir les policiers et les gendarmes
c'est-à-dire un chef extrêmement haut
ils font partie des fonctionnaires les
et les personnalités des métiers les
plus appréciés des Français voilà ce que
je veux dire en quelques mots monsieur
le Président merci Monsieur le Ministre
d'abord je remercie pour avoir poursuivi
cette audition un petit peu au-delà de
l'heure prévue et je pense que le
président le président de la commission
des lois Sénat
si vous avez besoin de mot d'excuse vous
nous dites merci
on se retrouve à 14h30 pour l'examen des
pétitions